[Music]
all right here we go Mike Moll are good
to see you man thank you a pleasure
welcome time a long time coming
delighted to meet you can't wait to get
into all of this stuff with you man
you're you're a fascinating dude there's
so many areas that we could explore but
I think the first thing I want to launch
into the thing that's kind of top of
mine for me personally and I think
probably with the audience yeah is your
your interest and your research and
specificity in the area of hormone
optimal yeah sure sure really cool so
first of all like well how did you get
as a strength coach as a fitness person
personality instructor whatever you want
to call it how did you decide to dive
deep into this area because it's kind of
a it's the bastard stepchild of
everything else Fitness but of course
essential to optimal health and athletic
performance
yeah it's critical for athletic
performance and just feeling good even
for people who don't work out if they
just want to feel good and vital I got
into it because I went through a serious
health crisis I was living in Los
Angeles I was around 29 so this is 2002
mm-hmm and I had a lot of stress going
on at the time I was in a really
self-destructive marriage my finances
were really bad just stress coming from
all angles so personal life stress
financial stress I was just getting my
business going and this culminated in me
getting a serious case of pneumonia
right where I nearly died from it and
being the smart I am I decided to fly to
Uganda to visit my parents while I was
fighting this pneumonia I didn't go to
the doctor and get a diagnosed okay so I
went on about 20 hours of flying with
maybe 10% of one lung functioning so
fortunately I was told the other way
no I didn't know like I said I was
really stupid at any time you have a
respiratory issue you go to the doctor
you don't mess around with that because
that can spiral it started off as maybe
bronchitis I thought I would kick it but
it just kept lingering for a long time
but I just tried to fight through it I
was just being really dumb about the
whole thing and I was scheduled to visit
my parents in Uganda I didn't want to
cancel out on the trip so I went but
when I got out there I just you have to
get me to an emergency room immediately
because it's probably 110 degrees out
and I'm cold
just had that feeling like your
life-forces way withering away so the
doctor diagnosed me pretty fast with
pneumonia just looking at my symptoms
they did an x-ray of my lung so you
couldn't even see my lungs there were so
much just bacterial fluid just covering
up everything so a long story short he
took a needle shoved it in my back
pulled 40 liters of what looked like
murky green tea out of me at 40 liters
went back the next day another 40 liters
but the first day when he pulled that
out it was such a relief and I was in so
much pain and discomfort he goes this is
gonna hurt I go look you can I don't
care where you stick that needle you
know at this point anything's better
than how I feel right now and it was
immediate relief so where I'm going with
this story is that when people say
stress kills they're not kidding you
know this is the culmination of stress
when it's not checked out so it's if it
wasn't for all those things that were
going on I wouldn't lead to this point
and then if I at least had done a few
early steps go to the hospital get
checked out
it wouldn't have led to this point right
so in other words this understanding
that it's not just yes you had a
pneumonia but what contributed to you
incurring that obviously like you know
severely repressed immune system
functionality exactly and then what led
to that well the anxiety and the stress
in the in play if that has on your
reticle your lymphatic and hormones oh
yeah 100% I mean I lost 30 pounds of
muscle during this whole phase and this
is when I was heavy into teaching
kettlebell seminars you know so I want
to look a certain way I wanna be strong
and vital this is 2002 this is a long
time ago so I gave my supp after the
trip I got back to America gave myself
about three months to get my fitness
back before I started teaching again
started promoting courses but I go I
need at least 12 weeks to get back into
thanks but I didn't want to just get
back to where I was I wanted to make
myself much more resilience than I was
before this and that eventually led to
hormones now as a fitness person you're
always thinking about testosterone
anyway so to some extent all of us are
interested in hormone optimization
whether we realize it or not but the
mistake that a lot of men make in
particular is that the overly fixate on
what's my testosterone level yeah
testosterone is important but so is DHEA
so is pregnenolone the mother of all
hormones you know so it's leptin so
since
there's so many other things so you got
to look at hormones as an orchestra when
an orchestra works in unison it's really
special like I was watching hand zimmer
on YouTube right does all the background
music for a lot of movies and he did he
there's a footage of him doing the song
at the very end of Inception and when
you watch the orchestra it's a totally
different experience than when you just
hear the music in the movie you don't
realize how complex it is until you see
it live how many different performers
there are and how the timing is perfect
and if anyone is off the whole thing is
going to be a disaster this is gonna be
a bunch of noise yeah well this is true
of everything yeah it's not just true of
your hormonal health or music it's true
with every function and facet of what it
means to be healthy and as human beings
we always want to narrow in on that one
thing like whether it's protein or
testosterone or even macronutrient like
oh let's take all of us and boil it down
to three things we're always trying to
reduce it down to one control group or
one variable when in when in fact it's
this interplay of systems that's so
complex and the you know this drive to
kind of reduce it down to one thing yeah
always leads us astray and yet we
continue to do well we always do and dr.
mark Gordon will say it's only if you
know dr. mark Gordon I've heard it he's
been on Joe Rogan's show many times he's
the foremost anti-aging expert he does a
lot of stuff with soldiers with PTSD
that's how he got into the whole thing
because a lot of soldiers have PTSD not
because of what they have experienced
overseas but because they had some kind
of head concussion and when you have a
head concussion your testosterone growth
hormone completely shuts down you're not
able to produce it naturally so of
course you're immediately gonna be
depressed and they go to the doctor and
they're just given antidepressants and
so forth no one looks at their lab work
but he does and when he gets these
people on testosterone replacement or
whatever the protocol is to get their
hormones back in the play he has a
supplement he makes that increases
growth hormone but sometimes they need
the real thing it's just night and day
they go from being depressed alcoholics
non-functional to being vital excited
about life and very functional but he'll
say that when you take
you put someone on testosterone let's
say it's trt whether it's a shot cream
pellet whatever it is you have to also
replace the hormones that are the
precursors because they get depleted so
if you just replace testosterone but you
don't replace DHEA and pregnenolone it
actually has a negative impact
why do they get depleted because the
body goes oh we have enough testosterone
we don't need to create the precursors
that's probably part of it
because that means historic comes from
the precursor so that's definitely part
of it I think the body is always looking
for him for some kind of balance as well
so when something goes really high it
just wreaks havoc because you have to
remember any kind of hormone replacement
is not natural you're taking an
exogenous hormone and you're putting it
into the body so it's gonna be complex
what the interplay is with anyone the
way you react will be different the way
I react and anyone else you just don't
know what the ramifications are gonna be
so I'm not quite sure why there's an
upstream depletion but I think what you
said it's probably a good part of it
right so yeah oh I'm low on testosterone
so I'll just get a shot or I'll take it
exogenously right or you know I'll take
growth hormone or whatever it is and
I've solved the problem as Americans we
always want to improve numbers on a
piece of paper right whether it's our
income or whether it's how much we're
lifting in the gym or how many miles
we've run so hormones are no different
and guys get very competitive too it's
like sometimes they'll they'll see their
number like oh man my testosterone is
650 I feel great and then they find out
someone else has 800 or like well wait a
minute how come now how come that person
has so much I go you just said you feel
great you know who cares what the other
number is this is the new this is the
new like pissy contest you call as your
buyer which like you were happy to tell
you tell someone else's number just like
your income could be it was like I want
make 300 thousand a year I feel great
and then you find out your neighbor
makes five hundred thousand all of a
sudden three hundreds not enough now and
what does it matter
exact all of your other hormonal levels
are thrown out of whack or or you know
that interplay isn't functioning
properly so you really have to look at
it and this is what you've done and what
I want to kind of learn more about that
sure is go to the go to the source go to
the origin and kind of an Ayurvedic
perspective of understanding that the
body works as a system and interplay of
all of these systems work
together as a whole and that when
there's an imbalance
you can't just supplement to cure that
impotence but you have to get at the
root cause of what is contributing to
that yeah yes exactly you want to
address the big picture and then
supplements come into play
supplementally so with the big picture
with hormones you have to look at what
are the master control hormones what are
the hormones that have the most impact
on everything else because testosterone
that's a downstream hormone that's way
down the line it's not a master control
hormone so for both men and women it's
leptin its insulin to some extent growth
hormone to some extent adrenaline but
definitely leptin and insulin being the
most and out of leptin and insulin it's
leptin that's definitely the master
control so we're all familiar with
insulin and insulin resistance right
like but but let's talk about leptin
that's that's sort of the bastard step
of the master hormones what is leptin do
why is it important leptin is our fuel
gauge it's just like with our car we
don't have to wonder when to fill up we
know when we're low and we know when
we're filled up so you don't go to the
gas station and just put gas in and then
wait for it to overflow and say okay I
have enough now and you don't wait until
you're you run out of gas on the side of
the road to realize okay I should have
filled up so what leptin does is it's in
fat cells and it communicates with the
brain it lets us know when to stop
eating so when you start eating a meal
leptin starts rising and when rep leptin
reaches a certain points you get the
shut off signal meaning that you've
derived enough nutrition from the food
you're eating anything you bet you
consume more is gonna result in
nutrients spillover you go beyond this
it's just gonna go into store body fat
so shut off right now now people are
hearing this going man that sounds like
an incredible thing to have I don't have
it but it sounds like a great thing I
got last time then I would need it much
yeah well that's what people supplement
with leptin well that's when people
started thinking they go they go how do
I I go the thing is is that people that
are overweight they don't have a deluxe
in deficiency they have a humongous
amount of leptin production what they
don't have is leptin sensitivity just
like insulin resistance they have leptin
resistance so the leptin signals not
getting to the brain the receptors are
dysfunctional
exactly and that can be from stress that
can be from poor diet you're eating so
much garbage there's so much of what we
eat is not even real food our body
doesn't even recognize it as food so it
just wears
leptin receptors they just get tired and
weaker and weaker and weaker to the
point where they don't respond at all
and now you just have this feeling that
your stomach is a bottomless pit doesn't
matter how much I eat I'm not content I
can just keep going do you think that
that's part and parcel of why you know
people that have chronic obesity
struggle so much with weight loss and
keep on off yeah 100%
another thing with leptin that's that's
really troublesome is that when you have
leptin resistance it lowers your
metabolic rate because even though
you're in this this state of consuming
excess calories to your brain you're
deficient so it's like well look we're
not getting the nutrition we need so
let's just go ahead and slow down all
metabolic functions so any energy that
was going to be allocated towards growth
hormone production testosterone DHA is
shut off because those are not survival
hormones those are basically thriving
hormones when you feel great
during the position of luxuries like
yeah let's get your sex drive up so you
can go procreate but they're not
survival hormones so now your body is
going to conserve whatever energy it can
just for everyday existence just getting
by right so now you're hungry all the
time and then you're tired all the time
and then on top of that you're many more
yeah exactly you would think that when
you eat more your metabolic rate goes up
but when you have leptin resistance
that's not the case so you're consuming
more than you have ever had and you're
not burning any of it and it's not being
allocated properly to useful you're as
hungry as ever yeah and your body is
telling you I'm undernourished exactly
so mister but your brain can't see you
in the mirror right so if you're looking
you're overweight and you're in the
mirror you're looking yourself going
okay I have excess energy reserves
everywhere that's really what stored
body fat is it's just excess energy in
case of famine comes right where we're
sin some ways were created to survive
famines so which we store our energy
easily as a result of that so I would
imagine it's also not as simple as that
I mean if you have a dysfunctional
digestive system over here if you're if
your gut you know if your microbiome is
screwed up and you're not able to absorb
the nutrients that you're getting which
might that's a bit
problem as well digestion is a huge
problem that's one of the ways to
improve EPS insulin Center leptin
sensitivity is most of us eat too fast
and I'm definitely guilty of that myself
you're in a hurry you just gobble down
something you barely chewing it you
really want to chew 30 to 40 times with
every bite but if you do that it's gonna
take a long time to eat but that's not a
bad thing mm-hmm because III tend to be
a big dinner guy that's my biggest meal
yeah I mean I have this huge plate right
and sometimes you just want to get
through it quickly so you can get back
to whatever you're doing sometimes
you're just thinking about dessert
you're gonna have afterwards so you
could let me get through this so I can
get to that coconut ice cream in the
fridge so you tend to eat faster than
you should but if you slow it down and
are more mindful like tic not on the
Buddhist monk he has this whole
philosophy of being extremely mindful
when you eat he goes eating an orange
can be a form of meditation yeah you
just peel it back and very good just
take pleasure in what you're doing and
if you're with people why not
pause have a good conversation rather
than everyone's eating and looking at
their phone the whole time and what is
that that process of extending the
digestion you know sort of time curve
what is the impact on that on microbiome
health well two things two good things
happen here and I'll come right back to
that two things happen one you're going
to extract a lot more nutrition from the
food you're eating you need to have the
saliva mix with the food so you're gonna
get way more you're gonna be way more
energized to you're giving yourself time
so that you're knocking it gets that
bloated feeling that just worn down
sluggish feeling like a lot of people
have to take a nap right after they eat
because they're eating way too fast
you're not giving yourself enough time
also you're giving time for the leptin
signal to get to your brain because
you're eating so fast leptin is telling
you to you you ate so much so quickly
that by the time left and told your
brain to shut off to stop eating you've
already gone way past this or plus point
well if you slow it down you have time
for that signal the satiety signal to
get to your brain so you're not going to
over consume either it's one of the
other benefit right there that's one
argument that's used against drinking
smoothies yeah you know that recently
yeah yeah I mean there's a there's a
certain
action within the the medical community
the nutrition community and even the the
vegan plant-based community that
smoothies are no no bueno because you
really need to take that time to digest
the foods you're eating but the
counterpoint to that for me is that as
an athlete like I'm not gonna sit down
in the morning and eat a massive salad
like I'm just either I'm gonna get the
nutrients in a smoothie or I'm gonna
just not do it exactly and it's a great
way to get a ton of super dense high
nutrient high you know phyto-chemicals
oh yeah that's in your body in an
expeditious way I'm definitely in that
and the blending is sort of a digestive
process actually I think I actually
think all the the negatives that are
brought up are actually positives when
it comes to smoothies that goes
predigested okay that's good especially
for someone already has digestive stress
now it's less than your body has to were
less weight loss is the priority I
suppose yeah I think someone brought
that up it might have been on Joe Rogan
show I think Joey Diaz brought that up
where he said that he stopped drinking
smoothies because I think when something
about blending the fruits your body
absorbs it differently and if you eat it
whole yeah I don't know about that but I
think I don't know there's a big
difference between a smoothie that's
packed with kale spinach beets hemp
seeds flax seeds blueberries versus the
one that's you know all coconut milk and
peanut butter and you know you're taking
in 2,000 calories like that's different
exactly different animals so when
somebody says a smoothie that can mean
anything yeah exactly I mean I I do what
you said I pack it with greens are you
ginger cinnamon nutmeg cacao powder
protein powder flax seeds hemp seeds so
for me it's a very convenient way to get
a ton and nutrition in early in the day
because like you I'm not a big appetite
guy in the morning I get up I want to
get my day going and then I think also
in terms of consuming it too fast what i
do is i dilute it a little bit more than
most people do so it's probably about 64
ounces and then i just drink one glass
at a time right I don't just down it all
and then they arcade yeah yeah I think I
think you can just take the same
strategy I just mentioned they're just
slowed it down to just take one class at
a time dilute it a little bit more
that's what I do I'll do one glass and
then I'll thermos the rest and I and I
just take it with me and I sip it
throughout the morning that just keeps
my energy
and it keeps the appetite up yeah it
makes me feel good some workouts I like
being on an empty stomach sprinting for
example I do ten hundred yard dash is a
couple times a week and I've always
found that that I like doing on an empty
stomach but if I'm lifting heavy weights
intermittent fasting doesn't work on
that day I'm not gonna go into the gym
and try to deadlift 500 pallets for reps
and haven't had a thing to eat that day
rice is not happening alright so back to
leptin yeah so what are the things that
that let's say you you have leptin
resistance or you struggle with your
appetite like you're hearing this and
you're like yeah that's me yeah how do
we write that ship and and get that
regulated properly okay
so we'll talk about the quality of food
in a second but just a meal frequency
planning taking longer stretches in
between meals is gonna help a lot of
people and it doesn't have to be extreme
such as and intermittent fasting where
you sleep eight hours and then you don't
eat for eight hours so it's sixteen
hours without eating some people do
great on that they feeling like a
million bucks others they're just
they're just this is not gonna work for
them what you can do and what will work
for everyone essentially is let's say
three to four meals a day with at least
four to six hours in between each meal
so let's say for the average person
three meals a day I mean that's what
most of us are used to your breakfast
lunch dinner so six hours in between
each meal what that allows is these
insulin receptors and leptin receptors
to have a break because when you're
eating constantly they're constantly
working as well so you increase the
sensitivity in between meals with longer
stretches that's interesting I mean that
cuts across the philosophy of just
grazing throughout the day as opposed to
sitting down for people do all that to
but those are generally people that
don't have any kind of leptin resistance
or anything like that those are athletes
such as yourself you know people that
are training really hard it's a
different story so I think it sometimes
it's a mistake when people look at what
athletes do going okay so and so in the
UFC's five times a day I'm gonna start
doing that too you have to keep a new I
can't take into account they train three
times a day and that's their whole
lifestyle rolling around that I mean you
can probably make the more frequent meal
approach work but for many people what
they're gonna find is if you miss one of
those meals you get a blood sugar drop
you get really tired now now you're
basically making your body less you're
making it more you're never going to
store body fat or
not going as much because you're always
focused on the calories that are coming
in and if you don't get one of those
hits then you feel the negative
consequences that's what I always found
with myself when I did really frequent
eating right so so in other words it's
it's trying to create a little bit of
metabolic resiliency by taking these
breaks right right exactly and then you
know several hours so you basically go
to stored body fat in between each meal
as well because those are pretty long
stretches so after a couple hours the
hormones decline and you go okay we need
to pull from stored body fat to keep our
blood sugar level stable so now that's
when another hormone kicks in the icky
or ghrelin which is a powerful inducer
of growth hormone as well and that's a
hunger hormone that lets you know case
time to start eating again mm-hmm but
it's also good to experience a little
bit of hunger in between me I'm not
talking about ravenous hunger were you
ready to pass out yeah but just a
certain level of hunger is not a bad
thing that's the other thing that a lot
of us get paranoid about especially
those of us that grew up when I did in
80s and 90s where you would read the
magazines to look at anytime you have
hunger you're a cannibalizing muscles
issue I first started doing the warrior
diet are you familiar with that or ehof
Meckler he's the author of that he
basically made intermittent fasting
fashionable before it became fashionable
this is back he maybe in 1998 or so and
he wrote about this going the entire day
without eating or just having light
meals very light meal such as a salad or
a few nuts but essentially a water fest
for the most part and then over
consuming in the evening and this this
website tea nation put this article
about and at that time especially this
is when everyone is deep into five meals
a day seven meals a day some even more
than that eight meals a day some would
recommend waking up in the middle of at
night and having a protein shake what do
you have to go to the bathroom have a
protein shake right there down that
because I purposely yeah a lot of us did
that because we're like oh cool I'm
gonna get more muscle growth by taking
that little protein shake head right
people really got crazy with it but when
you when I started doing his strategy of
essentially no eating during the day I
just I just worked into that it was
amazing how much more energy you had
initially at least for me because now
you don't have to allocate any time
towards eating so you're just focused on
other things and I would find that I'm
actually
I wasn't hungry I would get hungry when
actually if I started snacking then I
would get hungry so it was actually
easier for me to go the whole day
without eating then it would be if I
actually started tried if I had to have
a few light meals that would make me
more hungry now I'm not saying this is
the best way to go but what I bring this
example up that you realize that your
body is a lot more adaptable and
resilient than we realize you're not
gonna just cannibalize muscle tissue
just because you went a couple hours
about eating so it's like just like the
whole narrative of post-workout
nutrition right II let go if you don't
give something in that window of
opportunity that 45 minutes you know
that workouts a waste and when there's
the only study on it shows that if you
get a meal within 4 hours of the workout
you get full recovery so even that is
just clever marketing and generally it's
usually coming from a supplement company
yeah it's interesting how these these
ideas get planted at our heads and
become canon right before we really
fully understand what's going on and how
they shift yeah it was always you know
within 30 minutes that's what that's
your zone but your body's most receptive
to you know receive that kind of
nutrition right and now we're I think at
the very beginning stages of people
starting to understand the benefits of
fasting intermittent fasting water
fasting and you're seeing all these
people online who are trying different
modalities and variations of this and
sharing their experience and this is
really a new media alternative media
like YouTube so right thing right like
we're hearing a lot about this no on the
nightly news no not at all but if you're
online and you're paying attention to
trends and health this is this is
forefront at the moment I mean I know
Tim shieff just you know Tim shieff is
the new Ninja Warrior guy oh yeah sure
he just did a 35 days water fast or
something like that when he blogged
every single day of the experience and I
had Valter Longo in here talking about
the fasting mimicking diet and the rice
such and Panda who's a you know doctor
down in San Diego who's doing a lot of
incredible work in this area and people
are getting hip to this and it's cool to
watch people experiment with it and and
share the results and I think there's
still a lot that we need to learn about
it but this idea that you can't go more
than three or four hours without eating
is insane
right we're all of us we're over fueled
and undernourished like now right
right are we starving or are we obese
well right both yeah exactly
most people the last thing you have to
worry about is starving you have so much
excess energy that you could live off of
that for probably a month right a lot of
people probably could do the I'm not
recommending someone listening just go
not eat for 40 days you would definitely
want to do that under some kind of
supervision works you do it at all but
the fact that you can do it and survive
that that'll tell you something about
the way we look at food is a lot
different than reality really is is that
yeah missed a couple meals it's not the
biggest deal in the world yeah and and I
think we need to look at it from a
broader context than just muscle mass
loss or fat loss right Walter long I was
talking about how it stimulates tissue
regeneration stem cell growth that's
what it'll kill cancer cells yeah you
know but but create you know brand new
cells right healthy cells and I'm
speaking out of school and you know I'm
an idiot I don't know there are very
smart people that are looking at this
and and and discovering that there are
some pretty cool things that go on when
a growth hormone goes way up when you
fast insulin sensitivity improves a
great deal too there was a doctor on
Carlin or show superhuman radio and he
said just one 24-hour fast can reset
your insulin sensitivity so essentially
I don't know if this is just pervasive
across the board or categorical across
the board but you can either get someone
out of insulin resistance in a 24 hour
fast or at least improve it dramatically
and that's just one 24 hour and that's
huge given that you know pretty soon 50%
of America is gonna be diabetic or
pre-diabetic and this is all about
insulin resistance yes this is something
that they've been treating patients
TrueNorth for a long time you know these
clinics you can go to yeah you know and
they they put you on these supervised
fast for better either chronically obese
or have these chronic health conditions
and they see some pretty amazing results
oh yeah so again more to be learned
about that but all right so back to
leptin is there are there certain foods
that we should be eating that can
contribute to you know sort of making
sure that our leptin receptors are
functioning properly
I think I think the more nutrition you
eat the less calories you actually have
to consume and the more nutrient-dense
your food the less energy you have to
waste trying to extract everything you
need so when you eat so that we both do
you can dive so if you focus on a whole
food plant-based diet eating a lot of
fruits and vegetables legumes nuts and
seeds these are all really healthy foods
that are giving you a lot of nutrition
without taking in an excessive amount of
calories so focusing on a real food as
much as possible I always like having
some kind of balance of macronutrients
I know some people say you don't need to
waste any energy on that and I don't
think you need to be overly pedantic
about it but I think it's a good idea to
have protein source a good low glycemic
carbohydrates source and some healthy
fats at every meal and that could be as
simple as one of my evening stor fries
could be garbanzo beans with an avocado
added in or hemp seeds or pistachios
after I do the store fry mushrooms
tomatoes a variety of vegetables put
some spices on there and now you're
getting a balance you're getting
everything right and so when the leptin
is functioning properly the levels are
appropriate and the receptivity is there
what happens downstream well now yeah of
energy now that leptin is thriving you
have all this excess energy your
metabolic rate is doing really well and
you have energy that can be allocated
towards other things such as improving
testosterone improving DHEA improving
downstream hormones because now you're
more in a thriving state and those are
thriving hormones in particular DHEA
which is the ultimate stress management
hormone and without optimal DHEA you're
not going to have optimal testosterone
even if your testosterone levels look
pretty good compared on the range that
people look at it can still be improved
dramatically with DHEA because DHEA
protects testosterone from cortisol
cortisol is actually an anti
inflammatory hormones we always hear
about cortisol as a stress hormone and
yeah that's what it does but when you
have inflammation damaged either from
maybe poor food choices or you worked
out hard cortisol comes in as an anti
inflammatory hormone to address that
inflammation there's something wrong
with that but the problem is is that
when you're always in this inflammatory
stage you're always increasing cortisol
and if you're always increasing chorus
though
you're not in an anabolic State anymore
DHEA is depleted and without DHEA to
protect testosterone cortisol is gonna
nullify your testosterone and that's
when you get into this depleted state of
your sex drive is poor your mood is poor
you feel like your body's falling apart
you're weaker instead of getting
stronger these workout you're getting
weaker that's the hole that that I could
fall in from oh yeah I'm with the kind
of training that I do and the workload
that I shoulder and you know just family
life and everything like that is I just
fire on all cylinders and I'm just like
I can get I'll get it done you know get
out all that I'll crush this heat
workout and I'll go right into the work
day and family and all of that and and
on some level I think it it this is
totally anecdotal but it almost I feel
like it almost feeds my adrenaline like
yeah yeah you become addicted to it but
then I get into this chronically
depleted state right right and I don't
know if that qualifies as adrenal
fatigue how you would define that but I
know that my hormonal balance gets out
of whack because I tried to push myself
too hard I try to do too much and eating
a clean plant-based whole food diet is
great but that's not the whole oh no no
it's not the whole thing the thing else
though is there's nothing wrong with
what you're doing you're a successful
just success sex driven person and I am
as well so there's nothing wrong with
pushing yourself hard and wanting to
achieve impressive feats the thing is
that you have to balance the equation so
if I work out hard four times a week I
need to do some restoration activities
too I get a massage once a week I
started doing that maybe a couple years
ago and once I once I realized the
benefits of that are really I'm not
talking about just a little fluff down
she gets in there and works out probably
Active Release yeah exactly so any any
problem you created that week from your
workouts it's getting addressed with
Justin just build up it doesn't multiply
with successive workouts
I'll have days where I just go to a spa
sit in the hot tub steam room you know
just relaxation strategies do joint
mobility Qigong type stuff every day
go take long walks on my dogs clear my
head now you got to do restoration
activities as well so you can push
yourself as hard as you want and you'll
be fine you just have to balance the
equation yet the other things I'm not so
good
yeah I'm not I'm not the best either
it's actually that pneumonia story I'll
tell you that but I've but because I had
such a negative experience with that
pneumonia now it makes me I realize the
consequences of not balancing this
equation and those always you get older
I'm 44 now and I still like to lift
heavy weights and I still have goals I'm
pursuing so I can I can do those make
sure that my hormones are optimal or if
they're doing well and then I make sure
that the restoration is there so I get
the optimal recovery and how do you
gauge that through blood work for
hormones there's there's two other
things you can do you can do saliva work
you can do blood work now you'll hear
pros and cons from different experts
some will say they prefer saliva because
it tells you what's going on on the
tissue level others will say they prefer
blood because it's more accurate they
say oo saliva is not accurate because we
concentrate a lot of hormones in our
saliva as it is so you're gonna get two
schools of thought there the blood work
everyone is used to doing that that's
standardized the problem is is that if
you get your testosterone measured via
blood for example it tells you what's
floating around the blood stream mm-hmm
doesn't necessarily mean anything useful
is happening though is he getting picked
up by androgen receptors and you may
have a lot of testosterone floating
around the blood stream that actually
may be a negative thing and may be so
much floating around the blood stream
because it's not getting utilized at all
mm-hmm because those of us who work out
hard
we often have low levels of free
testosterone yes our based on the
difference between total testosterone
and testosterone
okay total is basically your life
savings this is exact this is the total
amount of testosterone you're producing
free is what you actually have access to
so you can imagine let's say you have a
million dollars in the bank but you can
only pull out a hundred thousand so you
have access to ten percent of the
million dollars free testosterone tends
to be low with people that work out hard
and in particular professional athletes
now there's a couple reasons why one
people will say well they're under a lot
of stress and so forth okay that's part
of the reason the other reason is that
androgen receptors are pulling it out of
your bloodstream to be utilized by the
muscles liver cells etc brain so that
the free level may be low because you're
actually utilizing it so it's not just
floating around the blood
right so so an indication that you have
low free testosterone isn't necessarily
determinative not anything yeah so you
don't want it to be at the very bottom
of the scale I say the scale is 8 to 25
you want to be around 12 13 now if
you're lower than that it may be because
you had a hard workout the day before
maybe you didn't sleep well the night
before there could be a lot of factors
so if you want to get a more accurate
number you could just take a week off
from training rest up a little bit and
then see what if you're free levels low
under that circumstance then you have
some problems you want to make sure that
you put some things in the play to
increase it but if it's in a good range
at that point and then let's say it's
lower during a week when you're working
out really hard then it basically just
supports what I just said it's lower
because it's being picked up it's being
utilized and then the other enemy people
often bring up is sex hormone binding
globulin they say all your free
testosterone is low because sex
hormone-binding globulin is attaching to
it and making it inactive and that's
completely incorrect - I mean six
hormone binding globulin is a
transporter hormone so it's what takes
testosterone the places where it can be
utilized so having good levels of that
is not necessarily a bad thing at all in
fact it's a sign of a good thing and
then you have to ask yourself why would
we have a hormone whose sole purpose is
to make another hormone inactive you
know we just produced six home run by
neglecting one for what purpose oh so we
can't use testosterone well that doesn't
really make sense but now people
understand it more as a transporter
hormone where it's actually attaching to
testosterone in taking it places not
making it inactive that's interesting
and so when you get blood work done does
he tell you like this is your free
testosterone yeah darker and this is
your total testosterone yeah and so if
what so so what does it mean if you're
your total testosterone is low or high
okay if your total testosterone is low
that means you're not producing as much
as you should be producing now some will
say the total doesn't matters to free
that matters and that's not true either
because the more total you're making the
more free you'll build actualize you
know if my total is only 200 how much of
that am I gonna build a free up to even
utilize if you only gonna bail to free
up a small percentage so the higher your
total the more opportunity you have to
benefit from utilizing more of the free
testosterone I see and and
what contributes to low testosterone
stress is number 100 percent is stress
and most guys are pushing themselves so
hard that you're in this stress state
all the time and every time cortisol is
going up your testosterone is going down
this is the way it goes so stress is the
number one thing and like I said it's
not even so I should say it's not even
so much stress it's just not balancing
that equation you can push yourself hard
there's no reason not to you so a lot of
times when people hear me talking about
this kind of stuff they're saying what
do you recommend that I just sit around
do nothing
I got no of course not I work out hard I
push my business hard I have goals I
have a lot of different nonprofits I I
like to supporting I want to put myself
out there and make things happen I'm
just gonna give myself the tools I'm
gonna take supplements like I've
designed I have a natural testosterone
booster which is amazing for athletes
because anytime you're working out hard
your testosterone is going down it's not
going up from your workouts so if it
worst case scenario it's gonna keep my
testosterone from going down and
best-case scenario it's actually going
to go up while I'm in this adrenalin
stay awhile I'm working out hard while
I'm pushing myself right so that's where
supplements come into play
sleep is number one if you want to
improve your testosterone and growth
hormone you got to get sleep in and I
like to get at least eight hours of deep
sleep at night and my lifestyle is
organized in a way where I can do that
you know I work at home I don't travel
much anymore so even if I stay up late
doing whatever I'm doing whether it's
playing cards on the strip or just
working on my business at home I can get
eight hours in no problem you can spend
one thing yeah
you know kids or anything like that dogs
week that's one of the things that
becomes an increasing struggle for me
and I don't know whether it's just age
or whether it's something I'm not doing
properly but I no matter what time I go
to sleep at night I'm pretty much going
to wake up at the same time and yeah
yeah like earlier and earlier as I get
older and so it becomes incumbent upon
me to be more and more diligent about
making sure that I go to bed early
because if I go to bed early then I
that's the best chance I have for
getting eight hours right and also
having you
a diligent pre-sleep routine yes that's
very important which I give myself like
a C I'm pretty good sometimes and then
you know it's like I'm out late I just
get home when I go right to bed I go
through phases I there's a there's a
really good program it's a meditation
program my life's called holosync
only people reused that and you can
download these programs into your phone
and then you can play it while you're
sleeping they have one that's that you
listen to you before you go to sleep
right it gets you relaxed and then you
put one on while you're sleeping so it
just stays on the whole tumbler I've
done certain things like that are they
certain tones that are that are supposed
to trigger brainwaves yeah I forget what
it's called binaural or something like
that I forget exactly the terminology
but that's what it's supposed to do and
you you definitely feel like something's
happening it could be totally
psychological it could be just be a
total placebo effect but you feel like
something's happening in a positive way
you just get more relaxed maybe it's
just the fact of of focusing on just
that you put these this meditation in
some headphones you just sit there and
listen to it maybe just that act alone
is relaxing because you're not looking
at your computer you're not talking
anyone you're just focused on the moment
right there right but that kind of stuff
makes a difference because I'm not a
good sleeper either I'm not someone who
can just watch four hours of TV then
just go right to bed just shut it off or
it can be really active and then shut it
off I have to go through down phases
where I get into a relaxed state mhm and
then the challenge for me is falling
asleep and then staying asleep because I
wake up really easily
any little thing yeah I didn't know
wakes me up and then I take a long time
to fall back asleep mm-hmm so I'm
getting better I'm getting better at
this taking magnesium before bedtime I
gave I don't want to plug every single
one of my products I have a transdermal
magnesium and zinc and MSM and the MSM
acts as a permeability agent to help get
the magnesium and zinc more into the
skin but magnesium through the skin
absorbs better than taking it orally and
especially on the cellular level and
people will find that if they put on
maybe an hour before they go to bed you
just start get some muscle relaxant -
magnesium and a lot of people who work
out hard are magnesium deficient and
magnesium magnesium is crucial for
testosterone free testosterone growth
hormone and insulin sensitivity we get a
lot of it through our food
kakaw in hemp seeds I'm a big hemp seeds
guy you get a ton of magnesium in there
but some supplemental on top of that
some supplements that thing just to give
yourself some insurance whether it's
mine or another option some sinc
magnesium B vitamins certain things I
think are used use worth adding on top
of the equation to make sure no I I do
like magnesium powder in warm water or
tea Epsom oh yeah drinking yeah like the
call it's called call yeah I think
that's magnesium citrate that's great is
it and so is there a vent is there an
added benefit by doing it transdermally
I think you get a better absorption rain
so you're just gonna be more impactful
but Xia may is a supplement that many
people use and it works well if you're
taking an oral magnesium supplement and
you find that it's helping you relax and
it's working well for you then keep
doing it does it have something to do
with melatonin regulation as well
melatonin being one of the other master
hormone yeah yeah I definitely helps
with melatonin production magnesium is
important for that as well something
about putting magnesium through the skin
also improves DHEA more than taking it
orally there's some kind of enzyme in
the skin that's activated so that's one
of the other benefits that's interesting
yeah it's not quite clear it's not quite
understood a hundred percent but there's
definitely a difference with the DHEA
production via transdermal magnesium
versus oral magnesium on the subject of
DHEA I mean that's a big one that people
point to if you're vegan say well you
know if you're vegan like good luck
you're gonna be screwed with DHA DHA on
a vegan people say oh you're not oh
you're a vegan what about your DHEA
levels once you've knocked off you know
it's down in the pad yeah but I've heard
it come up before well I like it like
Joe Rogan made a point when he
interviewed Lois Simmons now I love Lois
Simmons I think he's the best rent coach
out there powerlifting parallel team
genius but he was talking to him but I
don't know why it even came into the
conversation because Louie's not a vegan
or anything but Jo said Oh a lot of
these vegan bodybuilders take
testosterone you know because they're
not they're not gonna don't have enough
saturated fat in their diet to get the
testosterone production through food and
that that's in corrects
incorrect literally but it's also
incorrect for other reasons one there
are sources of saturated fat if we feel
we needed coconut oil cat cows so forth
right but you don't need saturated fat
to fuel this hormone chain you know any
healthy fat will do it whether it's
olive oil if you don't want to take oils
just get whole food fat sources as well
so whether it has fat in it yeah exactly
and even if we do need saturated fat it
has some of that as well and I don't
think you need saturated fat to fuel
this hormone chain I just think you need
good fats in general whether it's flax
seeds hemp seeds cashews and doesn't
matter so you don't think being on a
plant-based diet has any deleterious
impact on your body's ability to produce
regulate whatever the proper terminology
is DHEA and then there's DHA also DHA is
a that's an essential fatty acid
metabolite and that's that's an
interesting discussion too because a lot
right now fish oil is all the rage right
right and I'm not a big fan of fish oil
at all I think fish oil is at the at
best it's not causing any problems at
worse it's causing problems and I'll get
into that fish oil is full of EPA or DHA
and EPA right so these are downstream
essential fatty acids that's all fine
and good but if you take too much of
these it does lower inflammation but it
does so by suppressing the immune system
so unless you have an autoimmune
disorder that's not something you want
to do you don't want to suppress your
immune system rather than suppress the
immune system the lower inflammation
let's lower for let's lower the reason
for inflammation to be high in the first
place let's avoid inflammatory foods
let's avoid inflammatory habits etc and
then if you want to lower the need for
inflammation you take systemic enzymes
that lowers inflammation c-reactive
protein in particular which is a blood
marker of inflammation now way more
effectively in my opinion then fish oil
does without the negatives so when so
suppressing the immune system is not
good and then thinning the blood too
much is not a good thing either so I
think high dose fish oil is problematic
you have to remember fish oil used to be
something people threw away it was a
garbage byproduct of that industry all
of a sudden is like hey we can make
money off this thing yeah
I mean it's been hyped as this panacea
it's interesting that's that's a similar
story to how whey protein oh yeah
exactly
discarded exact product that they turned
into this mega billion dollars a guy
named Brian Peskin he'd be great on your
show I'd love to get him on my show too
he is he has researched this topic of
essential fatty acids exhaustively and
he doesn't have a vegan bias and I'm
bringing that up because he is very anti
fish oil and he's very Pro plant
essential fatty acid sources such as
flax seeds hemp seeds etc because he
goes you have alpha lanolin linoleic
acid and what that is is a parent's
essential fatty acid meaning that it can
convert into DHA and EPA but not the
other way around
and you will convert ala into the
downstream metabolites as needed so it's
basically regulated well whereas you
needed that conversion it'll happen
women actually convert a lot more
especially if they're pregnant because
the baby needs EPA and DHA are important
I don't want to diminish their
importance but you don't necessarily
need to supplement with them to improve
those levels if you get parent essential
oils you're gonna get the benefits of
ala plus the downstream conversion into
EPA DHA as needed that's interesting I
if memory serves me I think it was Chris
crecer on on Joe Rogan where they were
talking about this oh yeah you saw that
lb is a poor Chris was saying something
about and I'm sure I'm butchering this
and I'm gonna and I like Chris yeah yeah
yeah he's like and he really knows a lot
about a lot of stuff right you know I
like him personally but if I recall
correctly it had something to do with
the inability of somebody on a vegan
diet to to properly or efficiently do
this conversion process that's that
create a problem right well I mean even
if that's the case there's still options
marine algae there's still are options
that are vegan that are sources of brain
Michael Greger did a video on on fish
oil and sort of debunking some you know
panacea hyperbole around it and he was
saying that that even like they tested a
whole variety of like the
cleanest the supposedly cleanest
versions and they still found some
pretty high levels of mercury toxicity
in them yeah so even ones that were
saying like we're mercury free still
tested right so it's always advisable to
use an algae based yeah I think so too
exactly so if you're gonna go that route
I really personally I don't even think
that's necessary unless for some reason
you've done testing and you find that
you're really deficient in DHA EPA and I
believe there are right I believe there
are tests for that there are essential
fatty acid tests but but you don't think
that's really where we should be focused
I don't think so I'm always I'm always
focused on what the big picture is right
when it comes to weightlifting I focus
on compound exercises when it comes to a
hormone optimization I focus on what are
the master control hormones that have
the most impact the downstream is met is
important as well and we should address
that but let's focus on the big picture
and then anything we need to do
supplemental we done get into I want to
go back to the big picture of master
hormones but but we touched on
testosterone and I want to just kind of
see that through sure so a lot of guys
you know I'm 51 now I'm gonna be 52 soon
a lot of guys in my age bracket are like
well my testosterone is low and that's
just because that's what happens when
you get older right or you know I'm
genetically predisposed to low
testosterone and you know this is just
is what it is and my doctors
recommending hormone replacement therapy
I know a lot of guys that are doing this
right now so again this is something
that's specifically focused on just this
one downstream hormone right but what do
you say to the person who says look I
got low tea there's nothing I can do
about it it just is what it is well one
if you're gonna go that route that's
fine that's your choice but just make
sure you're working with someone like
dr. more at Gordon's someone very
knowledgeable or not dr. Nick Delgado
people that know what they're doing so
that they can make sure that you're
getting the full benefits of hormone
optimization not just replacing
testosterone make sure everything else
is working in that Orchestra you're
probably gonna have to replace a few
other hormones to pregnenolone DHEA in
particular but if you focus on on
regulating the master hormones ya
downstream effects should take care of
it so I think so I mean certain people
those there's a couple things one you
know at a certain age
I mean body would go low when you get
yeah I said a certain age this there's
gonna be an inevitable decline so then
you have to ask yourself okay I'm 60 now
you know how people come to me they're
going look I'm 70 I've been diagnosed
with low testosterone but I don't want
to shut down my own production I get
well look you're 70 you're your own
production the store has been closed for
a while your production is is very poor
let's be really honest there and how
much time do you want to waste trying to
figure out how to get it back naturally
even if that's if that's even possible
and I've had older people use my natural
testosterone booster with great results
but a lot of people that are at a
certain age it's just not going to come
back to arraign to well to a level
that's good for you because here's what
I mean by that also is you may be seven
in your total testosterone is 500 and
that's considered a pretty good number
but for you to feel your best this
person in particular they need to be
they may need to be at 8 or 900 to feel
perfect or their sex drive is good their
mood is good and they just feel like
taking charge of the day now can that
person get back there naturally let's
take a look at what's going on in their
lifestyle before we answer that is they
are they sleeping properly if the answer
is no then okay let's improve your sleep
it's their diet part all right let's
improve that how much stress is going on
in their life let's improve that you can
try to improve all those other things
and then see what happens or you can
have the attitude of look I don't want
to change anything else you know just
give me the testosterone yeah they have
to modify their lifestyle habit I do uh
had high cholesterol and the doctors I
look we can either change your diet or
we can get you on lipitor it's like okay
I'll just take the lipitor all right
there's a reason why that drug is so
successful but at some point though
you're gonna you're gonna be doing
everything right and it's still not
gonna be working any avail and that
doesn't necessarily mean you need
testosterone replacement you may need to
try something like clomid which is a
fertility drug that dr. mark Gordon's
been using with a lot of his patients
and he has them do 50 milligrams every
third day and this is basically a it's
an anti estrogen but a very interesting
anti estrogen it lowers estrogen in the
brain which signals your brain to
produce more luteinizing hormone in FSH
so for for some reason the low levels of
estrogen in the brain signals the testes
to produce more testosterone
quite understand why this is the case I
have a theory my theory is that for men
a lot of our estrogen comes from
testosterone conversion and estrogen
rightthey from the aroma taste enzymes
so it's possible that low levels of
estrogen detected in the brain you may
be trying to produce more testosterone
so that you convert some of it back to
estrogen but that's just my theory
that's a separate point but what clone
made he'll have before even going the
TRT route they'll try this because this
drives up your own production of
testosterone which is what you want to
do right and also it fuels the entire
bus Assam I go well what about DHA and
pregnenolone
does it improve those as well he goes
yeah that's what we've seen so it's not
just improving testosterone it's
improving the entire chain so that's a
more comprehensive switch now there's
some that say there's some side effects
some say that's there's ocular potential
eye damage that can occur which he says
it's not the case dr. Gordon that's only
if you go way too high so again these
are these are drugs these are medicines
this is not something where you want to
say wow that Columbus sounds interesting
let me go buy some from offshore start
playing around with it yeah let's be
very clear like I'm not a doctor I don't
play one on the internet them yeah Melia
is like I'm not recommending anything
here I think anybody who's listening to
this needs to seek out the best
professional advice they can get yeah
I'm more of a researcher an enthusiast
I'm just hoping to get people to start
the conversation with it yeah so when
they hear this they go you know what
that's not something I've ever looked
into I need to look into that and I need
to find someone that can guide me on
that process and they're focused on you
know building their strength or losing
weight right that's kind of where it
ends and you know like we said at the
outset like this is a complicated array
of many systems that work together and
yeah this system of hormone regulation
doesn't get enough bandwidth which is
well no it doesn't talk to you today we
were talking with your crew I go you
know hormones have way more effect on
how you think in field and the other way
around
so if you're depressed and you're
thinking let me just think a certain way
and I'll feel better or you can improve
your hormonal profile and you'll
automatically feel better so that to me
is just more efficient on the subject of
testosterone is there a biological
rationale or imperative as to why it
would reduce as you get older
and what is the if any the long-term is
there a long-term negative implication
to taking it exogenously or yeah
therapeutically yeah those are good
questions I mean never want I'd like you
should do it it's like you know you're
messing with this system yeah and you
are what are you actually
you're gonna repress your body's own
ability to produce it right endogenously
that's right but what else is it doing
right suddenly boosting your system with
this incredibly powerful hormone
well apparently has a lot of health
benefits it improves heart health and
many other things improves brain health
now they're more and more research is
coming out about the importance of
testosterone with pushing off dementia
with any kind of decline in cognitive
health so I think I don't think there's
any negatives if you're doing it
properly so in other words under a
doctor's supervision so but if it's
going too high in there and you're
you're having these chemical reactions
that your individual endocrinology is
having is having a negative impact you
want to catch those things early and
that's what a good doctor will deal
they'll go okay your liver enzymes are
too high so we need to reduce this or
your converting way too much to a
stretch in that happens a lot people
take testosterone and their levels go
way up and now their estrogen goes way
up too so now they got to get you on
something else to block that conversion
of course your choice it gets complex
right yeah it's kind of like you go to
the doctor and you go my cholesterol is
too high then you get a lipitor and then
you go you know and then look at one of
the negatives of lipitor is you start
losing memories and you start having a
decline in sex drive or total shutdown
of sex function so now you got to go
back and go okay my sex drive is not
working okay well here some by agra now
you're on two medications then you gotta
take something else for the negatives of
that so it could become I'm not saying
that TRT should be the first line of
defense I don't think it should be you
know I don't use testosterone
replacement therapy and I'm 44 and my
testosterone levels are great but I
thought but I don't think it should be
ruled out as an option either I think
some people are in such a depleted state
like for example these people dr. mark
Gordon works with who have PTSD from
head trauma think about how many of us
have had head trauma that we just don't
think about now I went snowboarding when
I was 15 one time and I had a really
nasty fall my head boom hit the ice that
could have had a negative impact or no
more hormone production a lot of us have
been in car accidents where we had some
kind of
it doesn't take much you know the brain
is delicate so if you have any kind of
damage to your pituitary gland
you're not going to produce testosterone
growth hormone naturally and certainly
not to the full benefit of your
potential right Wow all right let's talk
about insulin let's uh you know maybe
we'll well debunk a few myths I mean
it's impossible to talk about insulin
and insulin resistance without the
subject of sugar coming up and diabetes
right and your experience in your
research and everything that you've
learned like what is contributing to
insulin resistance and why is this a
master or hormone and how can we best
ensure that we're regulating it properly
it's a complex subject because there's
so many intelligent people that have
different views on the topic so I can
understand why the average person gets
confused you know on one hand you have
people like dr. Nick Delgado who say
that high levels of fat caused the
insulin receptors to be weakened so that
they can't process glucose properly and
now you have high glucose levels as a
result Neal Barnard says something
similar yeah and I dr. Gork Davis I
think you've had him on the show you
know that he basically talks about it
because it's not sugar is not the
problem it's your but insulin can handle
sugar the problem is when you have way
too much fat in his warts in particular
animal fat that dulls these receptors
now you can't handle the sugar right now
and when these guys come out and say
this it provokes quite the response oh
yeah like I love Garth
I love Neal like I trust these people
and I know like both of them have done
extensive research right and I believe
them but that's anathema to the
conventional wisdom that this is a sugar
thing and a sugar thing only well I
think I think it's probably more complex
than either one person's right or wrong
all the time you know they may be right
in certain circumstances while other
people who talk about high sugar
consumption being a prom they could be
right regarding other people in certain
certain circumstances meaning that some
people could have pre-diabetes and
insulin resistance because of high sugar
consumption this is the way they're
metabolizing it other people could have
the same diet and not have any issues
right so we're all very complex
different things we're going to have
different
biochemical reactions no matter what the
case is I think the way to to cut
through all of this debate is to look at
the common ground of let's focus on
reducing garbage food because that has
no benefit maybe it's not causing
diabetes maybe it's not causing my
glucose but it has other problems let's
just cut it out anyway because what the
last thing we want people thinking is
that okay sugars not the prom well I'll
just cut back on fatty need a lot of
sugars like that's not good either yeah
clear life I'm not saying and I would
never say that that just eating sugar is
Meli I'm addict you know and when I say
sugar I'm talking about refined [ __ ]
like that
yeah but can we can we at least say that
like this idea that you're gonna get
diabetes from eating fruit is no it's
ridiculous
I pad and I've had I've seen people
posts up such as oh here's a candy bar
no difference between that and fruit I
got so absurd I had a guy at the dog
park asked me he goes you know I love
eating a banana every day but someone
told me it's really bad for you I go
come on huh I go banana one banana is
bad for you let's let's get real here so
no I think I think this carbohydrate
phobia that society has right now and I
noticed that at least when I lived in
Los Angeles I noticed that bread stores
never made it
hi great harvest didn't have a location
out here because everybody's on this
low-carb cake or at least they think
they are I mean it's kind of like the
whole low-fat crazy never really happen
people go and remember when everyone did
low-fat and everyone got fatter and it
didn't work yeah but no one did it
exactly but no one did it what they did
is added more low-fat packaged foods to
their existing high-fat diet
super highly processed so nobody nobody
cut nobody cut out all this fat and just
drank orange juice and cornflakes they
did that on top of everything else this
whole low-fat craze has never happened
now I'm all about balance and it doesn't
have to be 30% this 40% that 30% that
but I think you we all need the older
macronutrients some are gonna do better
on more fat less carbohydrates some more
carbohydrates less fat you don't know
until you try I find that for heavy
weight lifting I like to have a good
amount of fat in my diet and I just I
don't keep track of this stuff I just
add it to meals and so forth I just made
I make sure I have good fatty sources so
I think that
with insulin resistance though let's cut
back in all the crappy food that we
shouldn't be indulging in anyway let's
start there because that's definitely
not helping just says the way it causes
leptin resistance leptin and insulin are
intertwined so if you have leptin
resistance you have insulin resistance
and if you improve leptin sensitivity
you improve insulin sensitivity so let's
do all the same things that we just
mentioned for leptin now when it comes
to carbohydrates if you meet a lot of if
you're out let's say you're on a
plant-based diet and you're eating
legumes nuts and seeds fruits and
vegetables and you do it for 90 days oil
free and your blood sugar doesn't
improve which I would find hard to
believe I would think your blood sugar
would improve a lot but let's say it
doesn't okay at that point let's start
playing around because 90 days is long
enough to see whether you should have an
improvement probably don't even need
that long but it's certainly long enough
but if you have a traumatic brain injury
stressed out and you're not sleeping
yeah
exact you can eat whatever you want but
that's also true see that's the other
thing that people don't think about is
that it may not even be what you're
eating it could be everything else
that's going on in your life so where it
gets all right so so cut out all the
lousy processed foods longer stretches
in between meals just like that improves
leptin that improves insulin sensitivity
intermittent fasting improves insulin
sensitivity a great deal as well there
so you may find that your blood sugar
improves a lot now you have to be
careful especially depending on you know
what kind of diabetic you are some if
they if they go too long without a meal
they can have a blood sugar crash exact
yeah that can be a problem as well but
let's just say you're somebody who's
maybe teetering on the precipice of
being pre-diabetic or perhaps you're
even insulin resistant and you don't
even know it like what are the
downstream you know setting diabetes
aside like what are the downstream
implications of just having sub-optimal
insulin receptivity
yeah when insulin doesn't work well
cortisol has to come in and pick up some
of the slack you know to get glucose
where needs to go and then anytime you
have an increase in cortisol you're
gonna have a negative impact on
testosterone so when insulin is not
working properly
cortisol comes into play and then when
cortisol goes up that has a negative
impact on testosterone DHEA and so forth
right so that's all intertwined in that
respect but all of the like the sort of
top-line lifestyle protocol
to regulate these master hormones seem
to be the same whether it's whether it's
insulin or leptin or or what are the
other ones melatonin
yeah melatonin is important growth
hormones know the adrenaline at Ronald
renal fatigue is a big thing but we're
talking about adrenal fatigue earlier
where you're like I'm not sure if I have
it well one easy way to know whether you
have it is if you wake up tired let's
say you slept for eight hours and you
wake up and you're still tired and you
don't you have to get that cup of coffee
and to go and I'm a coffee drinker I
enjoy coffee but my attitude is always
if you need a cup of coffee then you
have a problem you should skip it if you
enjoy a cup of coffee that's different
in other words I wake up I'm excited I'm
energetic and then I love having a cup
of coffee kick back in my backyard and
just get my day going right it's a nice
ritual but that's not most people's
experiences most people they get up
they're tired you know they don't get
their motor going until they get a cup
of coffee it's kind of like imagine your
car battery is dead every time you come
home and you have to charge it in the
morning to get going well that's a big
inconvenience but that's what most
people are doing they wake up tired they
need some kind of stimulant whether it's
coffee or some other stimulant redbull
etc to get their day going that's
extremely problematic and then what
happens is your adrenals don't kick in
because you want cortisol to be high in
the morning and low in the evening so
you're desperately trying to get the
cortisol output so you can get through
your day to no avail and then it happens
late at night it finally kicks in and
then you can now you can't sleep right
so you're stuck on this vicious cycle of
I'm tired I'm tired in the morning and
then I'm tired all day and then just
what I think I can go okay fine let me
just wind down now I'll be better
tomorrow boom it kicks in then you lie
in bed you're going I'm just tossing and
turning so Charles Poliquin has a really
good strategy for him for flipping this
he recommends licorice supplements and
what licorice does is it actually
increases cortisol and conversion into a
longer-lasting cortisol so that if you
take it in the morning you get a
cortisol boost I mean you take it in the
afternoon you get another one and then
what happens is your cortisol naturally
goes down and evening as a result of
that flipping it and you only need to do
it for about a week right we've 210 days
now some will say all that increases
high blood pressure it's like okay if
you have high blood pressure
be careful again even with supplements
we want to make sure you're getting
checked out before you add anything to
your regimen so that's important and the
other thing is there : well I thought I
heard that increases estrogen I was like
yeah
it increases estrogen in menopausal
women terrified yeah yeah you got a
better look at where it's like yeah II
did show that you increases estrogen
with menopausal women are you a
menopausal woman then you sit there for
naught then you don't even in the Word
of God right and it's a week to 10 days
you're not getting on it for a year I've
used it many times right go through
periods where you just crash Riley you
were talking about that sometimes you're
just you just crash from doing stuff and
then I'll wake up and I'm tired I'm like
going man I'm just exhausted like your
arms feel really heavy I hate that
feeling your arms feel heavy just feel
tired you're like man I don't know how
I'm gonna get anything done today and
then whenever that happens now though I
just have a bottle on hand at all times
metagenic makes a really good one it's
vegan no gelatin caps and it's a tablets
you just chew it it tastes like licorice
I chew it just to digest it better and
one tablet in the morning one in the
afternoon for about ten days seven to
ten days and then you're good no flips
it you feel way better I'm gonna try
that yeah that makes a big Poliquin is
also the guy who said you couldn't be a
successful athlete on a vegan diet
anybody he also brought up my name in
that question you prep you stop Brendan
real yeah that's where I'm friends with
Charles and he's been on my podcast many
times and I've always had a good
relationship with Charles I think he's a
very smart strength coach but he comes
from that old guard up you got to eat a
lot of meat right strong and that's just
what do you see the thing is is that we
look at professional athletes when we go
okay they only eat a lot of meat fair
what is that the reason why they're
professional athletes and performing at
such a high level these people are also
very genetically gifted and they put in
a lot of hard work and all that meaning
that they could probably have crappy
diets and still perform at a very high
level exactly
shocked I think so we don't have enough
professional AB we have a lot more now
than previously that are on a vegan diet
but until we have a lot more you know we
can't say that yeah it doesn't work or
that this is a superior way to go
because we don't have enough to go on
yeah I agree with that I mean I but it's
changing you know you're changing a lot
more and more and and I would
like it's a risk like if you're coming
up let's say you're you know 20 years
old right you're showing huge prowess
and promise in your respective sport
you're being you know you're being
you're the next big thing and then
somebody's like well you should go vegan
like that's that's all yeah that's scary
so there's so much that you're wagering
than that like how many people are
willing to take that bet so it's a
hundred percent to date it's only been
like the the rare outlier who grew up
vegetarian or had the hippie parents or
whatever who kind of just were brought
into it and it felt natural to them and
so they don't feel like it's a risk side
good point but that's why we need more
examples and I had I just had me my
delgado in here the other day yeah I
just saw I started him on Instagram
that's a I mean you cannot I you to find
anybody with a more impressive physique
sure there's no but like how old is he
pretty young Gus
Chico's remember how old he is yeah it
looks like he's pretty young very
impressive I mean yeah and in the
sweetest guy he's never had me try
sincerity he grew up with Hari Krishna
parents really it's got a crazy
certainly interesting there's a lot more
than meets he's that dairy then though
growing up Danny when he went vegan a
couple of years ago okay so going toka
vegan is new but but that's really when
he stepped into bodybuilding in a big
way yeah and the proof is in the pudding
with that guy I mean he's like that
guy's physique is insane oh it's amazing
the fact that he's never eaten meat his
entire life yeah and that's important
that it's impossible for you to look at
that and go bro you know like all those
arguments go out the window but and
that's why I think he's really important
in this conversation but he's you know
one of the few and we're just gonna see
more and more and more and it's it's
gonna take a long time before we reach
that tipping point where a mainstream
society just goes okay yeah I guess you
can do that no definitely and then you
can't come back to your point with a
professional athlete it can be very
daunting to just overhaul your diet
because let's say you're a UFC fighter
right and someone comes along and says
hey man I think you do great on a
plant-based diet you go okay that sounds
good let me give it a shot and then you
go to your next fighter you just get
your clock clean right you just get your
but kicked it's gonna be hard not to
think well what did i do differently in
the last cabbie maybe maybe you did a
lot of things differently maybe your
training was different maybe you had
personal life problems going on but the
one thing that's gonna stick out is oh I
changed my diet that's gotta be what it
is right okay and maybe it was because
it takes time for your body to adjust as
I'm sure you hear this all the time like
well I tried it but then you know I felt
like lightheaded or I felt weak or I had
bloating in my stomach yeah and you know
it takes the body a certain period of
time - oh yes your microbiome do it just
to figure out like oh I actually need to
eat more calories that's a big thing I
visit people think it's protein but
they're actually under fuel like exactly
and and this you know there's nothing
wrong with a gradual I know your you
know your transition was gradual very
gradual yeah you know there's very few
people that flick this switch and go a
hundred percent yeah one day to the next
and you know it's not surprising that
that the body you know needs an
acclamation period yeah some people do I
know people that have flipped the switch
and they do great and then there's other
people that have done a more gradual
approach myself my mother is Indian
she's been vegetarian her whole life so
I grew up with her as a role model for
vegetarian she wasn't vegan but it was
there and I ate me growing up and so
when I was 15 I really got into animal
rights and I knew I just had to cut this
out I just want to go what happened
specifically well a couple things
happened its I was 15 and I was really
into a band called The Crow Max and I
know you know John Joseph knows cro-mags
are one of my favorite bands period they
had a huge impact not on just my diet
but I actually majored in religious
studies because I really got into
Hinduism through the cro-mags even
though I grew up with Divya my mother it
really got into it so it was when I got
into the cro-mags the bassist Harley
Flanagan was the singer John wasn't in
the picture at that right there's a
whole drama around and I'm friends with
both guys believe me I'm I know all
about every facet of the drama since its
inception I know every narrative of it
yeah and John's one of my best friends I
love it I like both guys so I'm not
gonna say negative anything negative
about either guy I'm really good friends
with Harley and I like John a lot so
here's the thing I was reading this
interview with Harley on the way to
Kenya because my dad worked for the
International Monetary Fund and we
thought it was important for us to
travel internationally so he wanted to
take us out to Kenya to go to safaris in
Sienna
in their natural habitat amazing trip so
on the way they're done reading this
interview with Harley Flanagan and he
talks about how he was always very
violent and aggressive and had all kinds
of proms and that giving up meat and
eating a vegetarian diet and leading
this Hari Krishna lifestyle really
helped him and then he said a line in
there that really stuck with me he goes
look we can't talk about peace and all
that when you're eating a steak because
that animal died in agonizing pain and
you contributed to serious violence and
you're trying to talk about peace so
that really stuck with my mind because
I've always even when I ate meat I
considered myself an animal lover right
I had dogs and so forth so I didn't
really think about the hypocrisy of it
until reading that so that was the first
seed planted the second was when I was
in Kenya and I saw these animals in
their natural habitat and you can say
well what about seeing a lion kill an
animal big see what I go vegan is then
what it wasn't that so much it just made
me think about all the animals that
don't live like that that are in factory
farms that are being experimented on and
so forth so that's there was another
light bulb going off in my head and then
I saw this movie the fly - and it's a
lot of people is probably one of those
forgettable movies remember nice lie I
don't know if I saw the fly - the fly
the original I don't think was all that
great the second one I thought was
really good and it touched on the topic
of animal experimentation pretty
profoundly well whether that was their
intent or not I don't know but that's
how you took it you wanna you want to
get someone interested in being anti lab
experiments on animals to show them that
movie because there's a heartbreaking
scene where this golden retriever is
experimented on and mutilated and you
see this animal in agonizing pain and
this that get that guy who becomes the
flight goes in and puts their dog down
mercifully but that made me start
thinking also about what actions am i
doing that are contributing to
laboratory experiments so anyway I just
wanted to change my lifestyle so that
I'm not contributing to animal suffering
now I know it's in it's it's impossible
to not do it to some extent just being
alive right so I'm not delusional to
think that I'm no longer harming any
animal in any way because I've been
vegan since I was 20 years old there's
25 years now but it's definitely
lessening the negative impact format
it's an it's an aspiration to create
less harm right
to kind of live in accordance with this
principle of a times that comes from you
know the heart that's the other thing
too Hinduism and Sufism in particular
really resounded with me when I got into
college I really got into those things
but I was when i when i first became
vegetarian my mother recommended that i
just keep eating fish and cut out all
the other meats by vegetarian mom yeah
she was eating some fish because of my
dad's influence at the time so she's so
that was kind of what she was doing that
whole pesco veg type thing and i was
like okay that's sensible a gradual
thing and then when I was 18 I cut that
out but I was still eating eggs and
dairy not much I was in college at the
time but I would have it and then I got
some literature on factory farming from
PETA or some other organization I forget
which one now this is maybe I was 20 at
Lewis and Clark College I was out there
for a year and that stuff is horrible
that's heartbreaking stuff to watch yeah
so I don't know how anyone watches that
and then feels good no but yeah well
it's a grenade it's tough either you
avert your glance and why do we avert
our glance like exactly like well like
wait in line to go see a violent movie
right but if you flash like an image of
somebody beating a goat or you know like
or a cow or a sheep we just I don't want
to see that because yeah exactly I don't
think about that we're all inherently
compassionate and if we really take a
moment to look at that will realize that
we're not living in accordance with that
compassionate disposition right I think
we all have and that creates internal
tension and anxiety so yeah better like
well I don't to look at that and then I
can just keep doing what I'm doing
and I don't have to wrestle with that
that just you know that discrepancy that
that internal yeah changing anything in
your life is can be difficult whether
it's a job you hate or a
self-destructive relationship or
whatever it is any kind of change can be
difficult even if it's something that
you hate you're used to it
so if it's it can be difficult to
transition from that and sometimes we
hear arguments now of like all vegans
are killing more animals than anyone
else because look of all the
deforestation that has to be involved to
grow these crops and they take out the
pay they forget the point that the
majority of crops are grown to feed the
billions of animal rider killed that's a
lot not the one personally I overlooked
yeah not the 1% of the population that's
vegan yeah all of that land that's now
being used to
grow crops for as feed for these animals
we would free it up for grinds right a
huge thing that doesn't get addressed
the other argument that kind of comes up
and I've heard Joe say this a number of
times like and I think he's he's sort of
aiming at more at the sanctimonious oh
yeah sure well it stands on a pedestal
that he'll say look if you're eating a
vegan diet but you're eating grains or
you're eating you know you're eating
conventionally grown crops like the the
the threshers and the you know the the
way in which all of those crops are
harvested kills all these rodents right
inside it's like yeah it does right it's
not about a completely harm free life
right about reducing our footprint and
your connection to that yeah so again it
goes back to the aspiration it's like of
course we're we're not current we're not
living Karma free oh no I don't I don't
you know it's not my place to judge
anybody's lifestyle and stand in you
know in reckoning of that like this is
just what works for me and if you want
to hear about it I'm happy to talk to
you about it that's the best I think
it's you know that's what's interesting
about you and your journey with all of
this is that you it's not that you it's
not that you hide it hide that you're
vegan but you don't put it out front
yeah and so there's a lot of you like
people come to you they want to learn
about kettleball exercises they want to
learn about fitness and then it's not
until they're totally on board and
invested and right in you and they've
learned something and then they find out
like oh my god he's weak like I know
people have known me for years who
didn't realize and it's yeah it's not
and that's a good point I'll bring oh
yeah yeah sure see when I first got into
the business I was I wanted to be a
strength coach and train people I didn't
necessarily come in saying I'm a vegan
strength coach I'm just a strength coach
right and that allowed me to reach an
audience that someone who identifies
himself as a vegan strength coach is not
going to you because once you say that
now people think okay I have to be a
vegan to follow his information his
training system is only gonna work for
that so that's just where he's gonna hit
me up with all this propaganda yeah
exactly anything negative associated
with vegans gonna be now I did write
articles about being on a vegan diet for
magazines and on my website
it's always been something that's out
there and people that know me know that
I donate a lot of money to different
charities and so forth to help people
and animals not just animals but kids
that are being exploited in sex
trafficking one of my favorite
organizations is Project child-safe that
helps kids get out of that world so it's
it's never been something that I don't I
don't have a tattoo in my chest and show
it proudly but it's something that had
that I've never hidden either this is
not something that I use as a number one
selling point I kind of like the idea if
someone gets into my information like
wow this guy's badass look what he can
do and then they find out like what he's
vegan too right then I think it's really
impossible where if I led with vegan oh
like people may not even look at the
message right then they're like oh I
don't even want to see that yeah
interesting yeah it's gotta be I mean
I'm sure you've been in situations where
that realization occurs and they're
right in front of you and you're right
like you know like deal with that as
it's like dawning upon that but you know
honestly when I was in in this when I
got into the strength world and I
started making a name for myself it was
interesting because in some ways I would
feel like imagine someone imagine a
black guy who has never been around
racist people and all of a sudden you
are but those racist people like him for
whatever reason even though they're
racist they're like oh you know we like
we like John let's just keep them in the
fold here sometimes I often felt like
that because I would be around all these
people that are eating meat and I'm the
one vegan guy at the table and people or
these people always these people had
very negative views about the vegan diet
like oh that can never work you know
Mike's just different no Mike's cool you
know I don't know these vegan idiots
always talking about this I can't stand
those people but Mike you're cool you
know you're flying right ha ha but it
felt like that odd man out ha ha type
thing there what does Poliquin tell you
Poliquin and I never discussed he
doesn't tell me anything in fact he
wrote a very nice article saying how
much he respects me because he's not a
fan of kettlebell training either he
thinks it's bad for the body and that
kettlebell swings are gonna mess up your
back which I of course disagree with but
that's what he thinks and but he wrote
this article saying hey I really respect
Mike because he does a lot of charitable
work and he's written some good articles
and strange training I'm not a fan of
kettlebell training I'm not a fan of the
vegan diet but he makes it work you know
it's always that kind of narrative was
like he makes it work no I find that as
well like in the
kind of things that I do as an athlete
the more you become the outlier
exception when you're doing it from a
place of like well I'm trying to show
that like anybody can do this all right
whatever but then it just it isolates
you even I've had a lot of people that
have gone vegan recently and a large
part of it was just my example and they
also conveyed to me that they appreciate
that I never pitched them on hey you
shouldn't be eating that way you got to
eat this way but they were watching
they're going okay let's he doing and
why is he doing it you know it was
terminating in their mind right so I
think the most powerful message you have
is your example you want to talk like I
have this motto live life aggressively
right take charge of your life now a lot
of people that message resonates with a
lot of people but the only reason why it
does is because I actually do take
charge of my life you know I live in a
way that embodies that motto if I didn't
that motto wouldn't mean anything so if
if I'm healthy and strong and vital and
passionate and then I'm also on a vegan
diet people look at all those things
they could mean I want to be like him
it's like oh you two vegan diet too huh
let me look into that a little bit more
so you're setting yourself up as a role
model without saying you're a role model
you're just living your life and people
find that impressive may want to know
more they get curious yeah I think we're
in this interesting time in our culture
right now where we're having a
conversation about gender in a way that
that we never had yeah I think that
brings up not just gender identity but
like what does it mean to be a man what
is mental inity mean and masculinity
gets oddly conflated with dietary choice
yeah in a very strange way and so well
you know it's interesting on that as
beer is considered a very manly drink
right let's go get a beer uh-huh and
beer is extremely estrogenic right the
Hogs and beer is extremely alcohol in
general SSO genic that's other thing I
didn't bring up before it's like every
alcohol converts testosterone estrogen
doesn't matter what it is yeah your
buddy Mike no Pete like and all your
stuff you're like no beer I have a drink
no I would let Barrett role in the why
alcohol is not your friend like you take
it a fairly hard stance oh yeah I'm
pretty out you take it pretty hard I
mean I have a drink every once in a
while must've never touches a drink I
don't have it at the house you know I
don't have like a wine cellar at the
house right like your and so forth if I
go out to a concert or something like
that or I play blackjack you know I'll
have a gin and tonic or something like
that I think someone who has high
estrogen levels and low testosterone
they should definitely cut out alcohol
at least until you get back into balance
mm-hmm so I just thinks the depends on
where you are if you're if you're fairly
helping you're happy with your levels
and so forth and you want to partake
every once in a while no big thing you
know we don't have to do we can partake
in things that are not good for us as
well you know so we enjoy it laughs a
little bit yeah you can have it not
every meal you eat has to be healthy I
like vegan desserts too you know it's
right not everything I do is under this
health umbrella but most of it is so
that when I stray on things it doesn't
really matter it doesn't have a negative
impact if I'm having a couple drinks
every night that's a problem yeah and a
lot of people need a couple drinks just
to unwind so just the fact that they
need it is a problem and you're
basically a functional alcoholic at that
point yeah it's like well I just have
three or four beers every night before
bed awesome okay cut it out for a week
well I don't need to cut it out there's
some negative downstream hormonal
impacts of that sansa load resistance is
alcohol it definitely contributes to
that
uh-huh and it definitely contributes to
the conversion of testosterone estrogen
adrenal issues you know again we're
talking about someone who's drinking a
lot yeah if you have a drink or two yeah
but if you have even one drink a day
that's not a big deal if you have a
couple in the weekend not a big deal
every time you go out on a bender though
let's say you get hammered I mean your
testosterone growth hormone shut down
for many days and that's not something
that's hard to believe
and anyone who's ever had a hangover you
know you're not feeling in an optimal
state at that point back on the subject
of masculinity and yeah there's somebody
your strength coach you're just you're
jacked you can deadlift 565 pounds like
you're throwing massive weight around
you were an early pioneer in this
kettlebell revolution yeah you're a you
know prime example of like this super
strong you know alpha male type
personality and so what's interesting is
is how that fits into like how that
plays culturally in turn
of you being a vegan and and and you
being a vegan for for you know coming
into it from a perspective of animal
rights and compassion so when right when
you think about what it means to be a
man like what is you know where does
compassion come into that equation and
how do you think about that yeah I think
compassion is the most important form of
strength I look at compassion as a form
of strength and one of the other reasons
why I have a lot of compassion for not
just animals but people and well in
particular kids especially kids that
have been through any kind of abusive
situation like I said one of my favorite
organizations is project child save
involved with them and what do they do
well the founder of project child save
is ty Ritter you'd love having him on
your show he's one of the most
interesting guys I've ever met and he is
he has a team of former operators some
of these guys are former Rangers Navy
SEALs etc and what they do is they will
rescue kids at gunpoint from human
traffickers really bad people that are
doing horrendous things to kids so
rather than try to go through
quote-unquote legal channels they will
go into country just bashing a sponge
blaze and yes like an episode of 24
right yeah it's like an episode of 24
when you hear the stories so they will
go in there guns blazing if necessary
and a lot of times it has been necessary
and get these kids out of these
situations so when you donate money to
them you're funding those missions is
that is that legal can they do that
outside of longed-for so here's the way
here's the way law enforcement looks at
it they can't publicly support it but
privately they don't disavow it because
they like what they're doing who doesn't
want to see a vigilante thing go right
it is yeah yeah it definitely is it
definitely is and if they get captured
in some of these countries then mm-hmm
you know they could be those do those
those operations take place outside of
the US or yeah yeah it's not having it's
not a raid happening in Minnesota or
some like that turns the other no it's
happened in the Middle East it's
happened in South America because that's
where most of these a lot of times it's
American kids that are being kidnapped
and smuggled over there because blonde
blue-eyed girls are very high premium
blonde blue blonde
blue-eyed boys are also very high
premium but there's any kid is a
potential target for this sometimes you
hear about American kids that have gone
missing and the bodies never found and
the reason or possible reason it's
because they ended up overseas somewhere
in some kind of sex trafficking slavery
type situation it's so hard to believe
that this is actually going on it
happens a lot more than we would like
and there's a ton of money being made in
this industry which is why it's so
pervasive and these kind of pedophilia
type people are everywhere there's
people on this street there's people in
my neighborhood they're everywhere they
infiltrate every facet of society every
ethnic group every socio-economic group
every political group it doesn't matter
they're around and that's why parents
have to be extremely vigilant with
protecting their kids and especially
after having Thai on the show I am
always keeping an eye on kids as a way
as in or the who's this adult and why is
this adult talking to this kid where are
the parents in relation to this kid
because these kidnappers know what
they're doing and they'll snatch your
kid in a heartbeat and I see parents all
the time that are on their phones
[ __ ] around and their their kids are
playing 50 yards away and they think
it's a safe neighborhood no problem but
I will tell you that he has profiled
pedophiles in person and he said that
they will say that they can go anywhere
with I believe you tell me what kid you
want I'll go get that kid within an hour
it's like oh you want a blonde blue-eyed
kid cool I'll go to this neighborhood
and snatch him real quick because no
one's watching that's terrifying yeah so
it is it is really terrifying and it's
extremely horrific and when you hear the
stories Tyus told about the kind of
abuse they've seen when they go into
these situations to rescue these kids he
told a couple stories when he was on my
show and then he prefaced it by saying
that's about a three on a scale of one
to ten and these were horrific stories
kids brutally raped on video you know
things like that it means horrible stuff
but he didn't mean I don't even want to
know what ten is yeah he told me three I
was like that's enough for me to become
a monthly supporter financially I don't
need to know number ten like you know I
don't need to watch factory farm footage
at this point to not want to contribute
to that I've seen it so there's some
things you just don't want to sow so his
organization had a real impact on me and
when you're
money to his organization it's not going
to someone's Hawaii vacation or for him
to get a new car this guy barely pays
his rent ty Ritter because he puts all
of his own money into this whole thing
that's amazing and you can tell me he's
in his 70s now so he doesn't go on the
actual missions anymore he's more
mission control he's the guy who plans
out stuff and he has younger guys go in
and rescue the kids but you can hear in
his voice that this is not something
that he could turn away from he used to
be a security guy in Las Vegas people
like Steve Wynn and so forth like that
right and then he started learning about
some [ __ ] sometimes kids would get
kidnapped and he would help get those
kids back and through that he started
learning about the larger picture of
kids being kidnapped and put into sex
slavery human trafficking and he said
that with my skill set I couldn't turn
away from it hmm but in some ways it's
ruined his life because when you talk to
him he's you can tell the emotional toll
it's taken on him you're just dealing
with his day-to-day the tough thing I
mean I had mark Chang yeah yeah I
support his organization and it's the
same thing I think he's doing better now
but when he came in here he was in a
rough state and it's because he's so
empathetic yeah he can't create a
healthy boundary around his emotional
state and what he sees and and it
impacts him so deeply that he literally
has devoted his life to this thing but
it's it was it was I don't I think he's
like I said I think he's better now but
yeah it was killing him yeah and it's
something I've talked to gene Baur about
also right you know from Farm Sanctuary
how do you do that he's like you can't
save all of these animals it's like you
can't save all the kids you have to just
you know do it you can do and find a way
to make peace without and be okay with
that right as you're in it for the long
haul otherwise it will just it will it
will devastate you and destroy you
that's what ty says too he goes he used
to keep track of what happened to the
kids after he saved them but some of
their stories were really tragic and he
didn't want that in their head meaning
that some of them went on to commit
suicide when they got older they just
couldn't deal with what they've been
through ah yeah exactly
some of them have gone on to do really
well though in one lady in particular
she called him up when she was a grown
woman and she has kids now and she said
you don't remember me but you saved my
life when I was a kid you rescued me
from these human traffickers which is
like I'll never I'm always gonna be
indebted to you for that and it was his
it was I think I was really glad that he
got a call like that because I think
it's really important for someone like
him to get a call like that just to know
people support what he's doing because
when he goes out and lectures about
stuff a lot of times people not answer
like oh I don't want to hear this
like I want to hear this if he just
freaked out like that it's like that's
not making the problem go away this
stuff exists yeah so you want to have an
attitude of coming back to masculinity
is to me masculinity is being very
compassionate very taking charge these
things so when I hear about that kind of
suffering I want to do something about
it get him on the show donate money
raise funds my friend Matt Brown UFC
fighter he he and he's not an emotional
guy at all anyone who knows him he's a
killer you know straight up killer he's
a great guy but he's like a psychopathic
killer when he's fighting but he heard
those episodes he's like look I'm not an
emotional guy but those episodes had a
real impact on me and he's been
supporting projects outside save sense
and he wants to do more you know so it's
just one of those things where a lot of
people don't want to hear about this
kind of thing and I get it you know when
I kick back to listen to a podcast I
don't necessarily want to hear about
this topic either you know but at the
same time
what are you Jay I thought we were gonna
trafficking yeah but at the same time
once you find out about this stuff you
have to do something about it and for me
it's a little bit more personal because
when I was five years old I was sexually
abused myself I don't we were living in
Korea and my parents used to leave my
brother and myself with a maid who acted
as a babysitter and we have some that
were nice but one lady was I always
equated her as that if you ever saw that
Mommy Dearest movie with Faye Dunaway's
it was like that kind of personality
right this was real hideous person and
so I was abused by heard multiple times
and when you're five years old you don't
know what's going on you know you can't
even you don't even know what to tell
your parents about what first of all you
trust adults oh you think that okay my
parents left me with this person so
whatever she's doing that's just
acceptable behavior even though it
doesn't feel good you know what's going
on is it's not acceptable but you don't
really have the capacity to handle it at
that point so what happens is is you
suppress that deep you bury that deep
and it's gonna come out of some other
point it's like a sleeper cell right
it's always affecting you it's in your
subconscious mind so it's always
affecting your action
but you're not aware of it and that's
what's danger he didn't have a conscious
memory of it not until much later so
once I was 28 and it was it was actually
not long after that whole pneumonia
incident I was watching this movie still
one of my favorite movies now Antwone
Fisher in Antwone Fisher went through a
very similar thing and in the movie they
showed that scene where he's around five
six years old nism he's in a foster home
and he's being abused by this lady and
that had a real impact I mean I kept on
watching that scene over and over again
and there's a scene at the end of the
movie where he confronts the people that
abused him this is really powerful
inspiring scene where he just said you
could you tried to break me you couldn't
break me I'm still strong and that
basically I lived vicariously through
that in that that's what I would have
liked to have done to the person to the
lady who abused me but I can't do that
because I don't even know who she is or
she might not even be alive at this
point and it doesn't matter because I'm
over it but that movie left an indelible
impression on me because one it gave me
total recall of what happened and part
of me starts thinking maybe yeah this
didn't happen maybe it's just a fantasy
in my head you know maybe I maybe who
knows what's real or not you're five
years old so I talked to my brother
about it I was like look I don't know if
you remember this but I just got these
memories of you know this happening and
he he got really choked up because he
does what he did remember he's like yeah
I remember that the older yeah he's a
couple years older and he has a lot of
guilt because he fought her off she
tried to do the same thing to him but he
was a couple years older and he was a
little bit more defiant than I was at
this time at this time of my life I was
very quiet and you know what didn't have
a large personality or anything like
that but my brother Roger fought her off
and I think at one point bitter you know
stuff like they really fought her off
viciously so she's left she's like okay
I'm gonna leave him alone so this is a
good lesson for anyone who's being
bullied you know how you fight back
you're gonna be left alone because
bullies are they're cowards and they
just want to deal with people that are
not gonna fight back so with me I didn't
fight back because like I said I didn't
know what you're supposed to do in a
situation like that you know you're five
years old snot like my parents ever said
hey if anyone ever touches you and
appropriately you know you tell us you
do this nobody thought they'd have those
conversations at that point you just
didn't think that was gonna happen so he
has a lot of guilt in that he feels like
he should have done something to protect
me and I basically absolved him of that
by saying look you're eight years old
man you're a kid - what are you supposed
to do you don't even know what's
happening
but that confirmed that it actually did
happen so okay now that I know this
happened it started making me think
about you know why one of the reasons
why I'm so compassionate to animals is
because I don't like seeing suffering of
any kind exploitation of any kind so if
I see a dog suffering or if I see
footage of animal suffering that that
hits me on a deep level because I know
what it's like to be in that position of
being helpless powerless so how did you
ultimately work through this well one is
I talked to it to a lot of close friends
I just brought it up and you know that
wasn't I didn't just call people up like
hey guess what I remembered it would
just come up in conversations and a lot
of people have been through the same
thing I'm talking about men here I had
many of my male friends have been
through very similar things just about
all of my female friends have been
through some kind of sexual abuse so
it's really rough and when you have the
courage to talk about it everybody else
does too because nobody wants to to bury
this deep you just don't you just don't
want people to look at you a different
way so a lot of people don't want to
bring it up because they don't want
people to think that they're broken or
that there's you know scarred in some
way but it reminds me of a story that I
read about this this world war two
soldier where he died recently there was
a CNN story about him and he survived
the internment camps in World War two
but he didn't tell his family everything
that happened to him then because he was
a young guy and some things he just
didn't want people to know about but as
he got older he didn't want to die with
this secret in him and the secret is
that he was raped repeatedly by Nazi
soldiers not only rape but it was a
spectacle where people would rape him
while other people watched and Lee
cheered and you know made fun of him and
stuff like that and he's a young guy
he's only I think he was 17 he lied
about being a teen Latino guy and he
carried this with him his entire life
and he never told his family because he
didn't want because they they held him
in such high esteem as this world war ii
hero and so forth he didn't want to
diminish that in any way but at the same
time he couldn't keep this to himself
anymore so i believe he told either a
family member or a therapist he just got
it out of his design of course his whole
family just was very supportive and
didn't change how they looked at him at
all of course they were very supportive
and they were just glad that they could
be there for him the way
for them was there for them so much in
their lives and then he's he just said
that the idea of me dying not without
anyone knowing about this would have
been more tragic than it actually
happening in in in Johan hores book
there's there's older women who say the
same thing they go you know I went
through this and I grew up in a time
where nobody talked about this kind of
stuff if you brought out for like whoa
don't bring that up and keep that to
yourself but for them they're actually
able to unload that burden at some point
in their life was really powerful for
them right so how did that so you saw
that and that impacted how you were
gonna deal with this or I think my
attitude is like when you when you when
you be when you go through serious abuse
you either have to embrace compassion
fully or you're destroyed by anger some
attitude was embraced compassion fully
now use this to be a stronger person use
this to be a better person and be more
caring be more resilient be more
vulnerable you know just be a better
person as a result of this don't be a
war sport those don't continue this
cycle of abuse don't abuse people don't
abuse animals don't none of that stuff
be use this as a fuel to be more
powerful than you could be if it didn't
happen you know make it a positive
people struggle with understanding that
that that vulnerability is actually a
strength yeah we perceive it as a
weakness and it takes courage to be
vulnerable yeah because you are exposing
your weaknesses but the strength that
comes from that and the strength that
can be given to other people who have
had something similar happen to them
is super powerful and I think that
that's also part and parcel of what it
means to be a man and to kind of imbue
this sense of masculinity I mean the
most the most alpha guys I know are the
most compassionate people you'll ever
meet
and they're also really cool guys - none
of them are bullies or jerk-offs or
someone who picks a fight at a bar or
talks to a woman inappropriately now
these are all really cool guys on
multiple fronts those behaviors derive
from insecurity exact yours
overcompensate that's all you're doing
it's like someone who picks a bar if
charged they get into a fight at every
bar that's not too much testosterone
that's not enough it's too much estrogen
if anything is someone that's
overcompensating okay I got to show
people you know how manly I am pricing
or someone who goes through gems like
okay I'm
lift more than anybody here who cares
right yeah so it's just those are just
overcompensating type measures is there
not coming from a real place of strength
yeah like I said the most alpha guys I
know we're extremely compassionate
people there they're always looking at
protecting people around them you know
that's that's the ultimate man right to
be the protector yeah so so you start
off as this quiet shy kid yeah you know
you didn't play sports and no I was just
I was a screw-up and I'm like DC area
now so I was really into the hardcore
scene not this great edge hardcore scene
that's just hardcore and heavy music
where were you cuz I grew up in DC did
you okay I went to Langley high school I
grew up in McLean Virginia right so I
used to go to the 9:30 club I'm sorry
yeah it was the spot that brains and
Agnostic Front and kromaggs and DRI got
into that scene a lot yeah so I was a
very shy guy not a popular kid in high
school and not confident at all in terms
of talking to people so I think this was
kind of an outlet for me it's like you
wanted to have those things but you
don't so like what's the next best thing
you go this new intense music from
people who embody it I mean the cro-mags
don't get any more confident that right
John and Harley onstage these guys exude
confidence and still do you know to this
day right so you're kind of living by
your kind of feeding off that energy I
didn't get more even in college I became
more social a little bit more confident
honestly for me it was a nugget negative
thing like my face got this scar I have
in my face is not VTOL ego it's called a
colburn where I was snowboarding when I
was maybe around 28 in Utah with my
parents and I got sunburned really bad
uh-huh and everything healed except this
area this is like a residual scar so
this darting to somebody yeah usually
it's just congenital or exactly so fetal
ego basically starts off as a small
white patch and then it spreads right
it's never something that that's this
big so immediate so basically one day I
didn't have this the next day I did
mm-hmm
and initially how can I just say I have
to interrupt you on this because for
people that are listening and they're
not watching on YouTube you don't have
like a discoloration on part of your
face right but the awesome part of this
is that on your goatee it splits one
half of it like perfectly down the
middle being white and being black so
you're almost like James Bond villain
that's the look I'm going for
yeah I got the Devils peak in the go
team yeah actually yeah that's why I
grew out the goatee because once I - do
you that - no no I don't have it I don't
have it there yeah that's ah this if I
grow out a beard it would probably be
white here and there like a no it's I'm
old I'm older now we like you dyed it to
me I too died getting full disclosure
right do died now because I've gotten
older it goes I'll come out great but
when I when it first happened it was
black of what I've just keeping that
look alright Keith yeah so the dust
that's when I embraced it instead of
trying to get rid of it because when I
first happened I'm thinking okay this is
just a temporary problem you know my
skin is gonna heal and then after a
while you realize it is in - how old
were you I was 28 yes I'm going to
dermatologists left and right and
they're diagnosing it as beetle eco and
I go well I've researched beetle you
know it doesn't make sense that that's
what this is you're born with it the way
it manifested right
yeah beetle Iike you can develop later
on in life but it's not gonna start with
a big patch like this it's gonna be a
milky white patch usually on the
forearms or hands sometimes on the
knuckles and then it spreads gradually
it can start becoming 50 percent of your
body at some point over time but it
never starts like what I have were boom
just comes right there from a sunburn so
anyway I would bring this up and they
would just be incredulous and say oh
it's just coincidental that this is
something that was always latent I was
like really this is something that was
latent this was just waiting to happen
if it wasn't that sunburned would it
just magically appeared like this so
anyway after going through a lot of
doctors I realized that first of all not
only did I go into these doctors I
actually went through the treatment for
V talega which is basically burning your
skin again they have this thing called
PUFA treatment where they expose it to
ultraviolet light at a high degree which
is supposed to stimulate pigment but I
would say that doesn't sound like a good
idea because I have this because I got
burned and they're like oh that this
will work and then I got burned again so
I mean it was almost worthy of a lawsuit
honestly because I got burned so bad
that the skin was peeling it was really
painful I go look this is I'm definitely
not doing it again
and even after that the doctor was like
yeah you should try it one more session
I was are you kidding me this is worse
than ya know it's just worse than it was
before fortunately it didn't leave any
permanent scars or additional scarring
but it was definitely something I
realized I was clearly not the solution
so long story short after going to a
variety of doctors to no avail getting
the answers I needed some recommended
getting on immunosuppressive drugs
because sometimes beetle ego is a
autoimmune disorder or it is an
autoimmune disorder where your immune
system is attacking healthy tissue
instead of just damaged tissue but the
idea of suppressing my immune system
didn't sound like a good idea so I go
you'll be more prone to getting colds
and fevers laws like that doesn't sound
like a good idea hey you know yeah now
I'm gonna have this scar and I'm gonna
have a flu and forget it so the final
stop for me and this is where I realized
okay you're just gonna have to live with
this is I went to this one lady who was
basically some kind of tattoo
specialists for medical conditions where
she said what we can do is permanently
remove the hair on that side and then
just color it and permanently I go well
that's gonna look funny that means I'm
gonna have hair growth here I'm not
gonna have it here and she goes yeah it
won't be perfect I was like we'll forget
it I was like this sounds stupid and if
you're like in the Sun and you do get
some coloration from being in the Sun
right won't affect that area exactly
this coloration anyway yeah exactly
exactly it's like how do you keep it
anyway it just sounded more complex than
it was worth so then I used to put like
dermablend on which is this makeup that
people have for scars right and I would
I would spend morning putting it on like
covering up this area and that work to
some extent in terms of my confidence
because I was really insecure about this
that's right that's where I left out is
that I was already pretty insecure
before this in terms of relating to
people but after this I was even more
insecure where I used to talk like this
right so you would be on this side of my
face yeah I used to do that I used to
try to hide it as much as possible I
have my hand here like that so I would
put the makeup on and I was working in
business developments at a company
called respond comm at the time over
there in Fairfax it was more for me it
wasn't because I was getting negative
flak from people I'm not saying like I
had a bunch of negative spiria like whoa
look at that it was this more in my head
you know you're being self-conscious
going home I'm getting looked at people
are staring at me and so forth so I
started doing this but after a while I
was like what am I doing this for
Who am I doing this for for strangers
that who cares what they think
yeah this is not my fault and I don't
want to be a slave to this where I'm
trying to where I'm not in break where
it's it's having a negative impact on my
life
so after wash now I'm not gonna wear it
anymore than I grew out the goatee this
is when I moved to Los Angeles so I'm
just gonna make this part of my look
that's just the way it's gonna be
because you can't do anything else
everyone has scars you know mine are
just some of the merges on the outside
yeah it's like God gave it to you as a
as this obstacle or like this talisman
almost yeah you to sit for to say like
look man you gotta like own yourself in
your that's right right like are you
comfortable with who you are yeah like
own it or are you gonna skirt it and try
to find ways of hiding it and continue
on this path that you're on it just made
me more confident me I did more public
more seminars and public speaking all of
that stuff I became way more confident
with as we know in Ischl II you're kind
of insecure but after a while I would in
some ways I don't mind I don't mind
being paranoid or insecure or nervous
because that means it's actually
meaningful you know that means I'm
actually gonna I like being a little bit
nervous before I give a lecture because
that means I'm gonna be sharper if I go
in there go yeah I got this and so forth
and then you blank out and you might
panic but if I go in a little bit
nervous I'm gonna be more engaged
everybody fitness fitness and strength
training came in before this though oh
yeah he started kind of got into it like
it's 17 or 18 I did I thought I did and
I got into it because partially I wanted
to build an armor so that I was
protected from the outside world and
what I mean by that is if I'm bigger I'm
not gonna get messed with because I've
been abused as a kid in the breast as a
kid I don't unconsciously I exactly it's
like I felt it was important to embody
strength II project strength exude
strength as a way to avoid conflict
mm-hmm it's like if I look tough and I'm
big and people aren't gonna mess with me
you know for the most part is true so
that that would that was well part of
the reason why I got into it also I just
wasn't healthy at the time I was
drinking a lot and I was doing a lot of
drugs I was doing LSD and just doing a
lot of marijuana and drinking that was
very unhealthy you know excessively and
I just didn't feel good now I'm 17 years
old and I feel terrible
yeah like I gotta pull it together if
you have like a moment of reckoning like
an epiphany or was it just like a
gradual I think was more gradual yeah
yeah I just start again I remember my
father bought me a weight training stats
just a banshan some dumbbells and
fourth and as I started working out more
I started feeling good from doing that
and then as you started as your physical
appearance changed that was very
motivating and then getting I'm more
into strength than I am
they're trying to be big and muscular
I'm more of a strength guy so as I got
stronger that was very inspiring to me
because I was really weak when I first
started you know I couldn't bench press
a hundred pounds I got pinned with that
but that to me was motivating I was like
wow I'm super weak so let's get strong
and every time you had a positive step
forward in terms of strength development
it was very motivating and it still is
to this day I love the feeling of
lifting heavy weights and blasting
through plateaus so you so you you start
doing this before college but then you
go to college and you major in religious
stuff that's right which is super
interesting yeah College you know think
about college is that I didn't know I
was I was I wasn't a good student in
high school until like the last few
years I did pretty well and that's why I
was even even I was able to get into
college because otherwise forget it but
once I was in college nothing was
grabbing me in terms of what I wanted to
focus on nobody's thinking about a major
necessarily as a freshman I mean some
people are pre-med and so forth but
that's that's supposed to be an
exploratory year where you try a lot of
things and I did and nothing gravitated
towards me so I I decided I wanted to
move to another campus let's try
something else let's go to Lewis and
Clark College in Oregon let's go to the
west coast
instead of being in Ohio I was at the
College of Wooster in Ohio mm-hmm and it
was I'm not as someone who necessarily
believes and you know everything happens
for a reason a lot of times I hate that
saying because it doesn't take into
account that a lot of the negative
things happen and there's nothing good
that comes out of video that's a
separate line but sometimes I really
believe in that statement because the
one year I was in Lewis and Clark
College the mentor who got me in
religious studies this guy named art
Bueller he was only there that year he
wasn't there before he wasn't there
after so if I didn't go there that year
I never would have met him and if I
didn't meet him I definitely wouldn't
have majored in religious studies so I
met him took a class on Hinduism liked
it familiar with him new wisdom I read
the Bhagavad Gita growing up and my
mother my mother used to buy me Hindu
comics and eggs are into this exactly
the cro-mags like it up down my mother
would buy us these comic books that had
Krishna and Arjuna and stuff like that
and those are that yeah we
we have a bunch of those you really well
you can get them at the Hari Krishna's
okay and you always ask like super
violent yeah they're like your original
super here and they're like the stories
are super complex yeah like they are the
Mahabharata I was sorry he grew up
reading those yeah yeah yeah so I grew
up reading those for sure and then I
took the Hinduism class it wasn't until
I got to Sufism which is Islamic
mysticism people like Rumi and rubia
Hafiz it was their poetry that really
impacted me this notion of being one
with God or one with your higher self
and not being a slave to your ego can't
get rid of your ego but your ego doesn't
pull the carriage you control a baker so
basically ego there's there are the
horses but you're the person controlling
the carriage you're guiding your ego and
that word that the so Sufism really left
an indelible impression on me this
notion of just living in the world but
not being attached to think so much that
it has such a negative impact on your
psyche you know striving for a higher
purpose a more cognizant way of living
that kind of stuff really resonated with
me that's the what I don't really
consider myself religious and I don't
call myself a Hindu or a Buddhist or
anything like that but Sufism is
definitely something that affects my
everyday life well it you can see it
infused in all of your writing and the
work that you do like this idea of you
know merely the existence of the highest
of your higher self or the highest
version of who you can be kind of plays
into that your tagline or ethos of like
live life aggressively not live life
aggressively like pound your chest like
a gorilla but be intentional with your
actions like have a plan like have have
a destination that you're working
towards understand the goals you're
setting for yourself and how you're
going to arrive there so for me when I
see when I what I read in to live life
aggressively is really live life with
conscious intention yeah yeah just
porpoise it just have have strong
reasons for why you do anything mm-hmm
to have meaningful actions yeah and
what's interesting about just just a
gorilla's
when I was when we went to Uganda we did
a guerrilla track out there so as my
parents my brother and I and when you
run into it when you run into a flock of
guerrillas they base are a group of
guerrillas they basically say that when
the silver but if the silverback
approaches you don't look him dead in
the eye you gotta you gotta lower your
gaze and challenge yeah yeah exactly
now Nick Delgado will say that
guerrillas know who the Alpha is in the
group that they come across so the
silverback is gonna challenge that
person and this silverback in this group
nak again this is not a this is not a
super high testosterone group this is my
family
but this gorilla stopped right in front
of me was probably about as close as you
are look me dead in the eye
massive gorilla huge bag this exuded
power you're like way bigger than any
massive bodybuilder but just exude it's
serious power look me dead in the eye I
didn't even have to think twice about
power I dropped to my knees and looked
down immediately and then this grill it
just kept going - Wow but that was such
an amazing experience to be that close
and there's no filter here - you know
there's no cage protecting this gorilla
from me we're right there this run you
end up so close though isn't that that's
gotta be incredibly dangerous it's not
something that they don't try to get the
gorillas to come closely but when you're
going on a gorilla track your goal is to
go out there and see gorillas now you're
not necessarily they're not necessarily
trying to get you that close to the
gorilla but sometimes the grill isn't
gonna come up to you and if you start
running they're gonna chase you know you
can't just run off or run up a tree or
anything like that you just basically
have to let them know hey I'm not
challenging you in any way right they're
peaceful animals they're not they're not
going around ripping people's heads off
unless they're challenged or you're
hurting one of they're young and all
that you know gorillas in particular
they don't have no chimpanzees can have
any evil streak and so for gorillas are
different than that so anyway that and
in there and then the group is just
gonna follow the Alpha so if the Alpha
doesn't see we're a threat and the group
is just gonna go with that right but you
could just it was it was like a scene
out of Planet of the Apes or something
like that you ran in the Caesar how does
that play into like what we talking
about I forgot I'm not even sure why it
brought it up I just remember saying
rail I thought was a funny story
like you like you have this sort of
online persona that's like a no-bullshit
like don't pull any punches like I'm
gonna time I'm a straight shooter I'm
straight talker exactly on your [ __ ]
and like your book is in that tone and
you have like this thing that you're
doing on Twitter now where you go like
once you start doing blank like there's
no telling how messed up your that'd be
and it's like a litany of like all of
these [ __ ] up things that like we as
humans can fall prey to that kind of
lead us astray right and so but like in
person like in real life like you're a
much sweeter guy than I expected oh yeah
you know I mean but I appreciate like
that no nonsense yeah you know no filter
like let me let me cut through all the
BS that you know maybe you've heard and
and and and and tell things to you
straight based on my experience which is
kind of the set title of your book which
is things that you know I don't know
exactly what they should be telling you
and I think it begs the question of you
know what's going on right now online
like a well-intentioned person can go on
YouTube or on the internet or on the
podcast sphere or wherever trying to get
good information about everything from
health diet nutrition fitness you know
strength training self-improvement
psychology right and there will be like
somebody there who's gonna tell you
something along the lines of like
everything you ever thought you knew is
wrong and go behind the velvet rope here
for this amount of money and I'm right
tell you right truth and and and and I
think the techniques that are being
employed are getting more and more
sophisticated like it used to be you
could kind of smell that from a million
miles away I think you still can to a
certain extent but it's getting trickier
to separate who's real from who's full
of [ __ ] right so how do you navigate
that see yourself within that ecosystem
and you know what are your thoughts I
just try to be as authentic as possible
in old format so what first of all when
I'm on Twitter or Instagram or Facebook
I post with my real name you know no on
anonymity no fake handles or anything
like that
so whatever I say I have to own it's
coming from me
that I think is important because a lot
of these a lot of times we see these
negative YouTube comments is never with
someone with their actual name there was
someone that just wants to ruin
someone's day or feel like they're
powerful I can get on social media and
just be mean-spirited and I don't like
that trend of trolling where people feel
that the way to empower yourself is to
diminish others or put other people down
I think that's a big mistake I think we
can have differences and be respectful
about it you like for example I don't
eat meat for the all the reasons we went
into but I know people who eat meat who
are very healthy so I wouldn't tell
someone you can't be healthy and eat me
my grandmother great-grandmother lived
in to be a hundred eating mean not a lot
but she ate meat so I think by that not
only is that what I believe but I think
by the fact that I'm not so dogmatic
about you have to do things my way if
you want to be optimal that makes people
more open for a civil discussion as
opposed to hey if you don't do this and
you're an idiot right they'll be here
that kind of thing too it's like oh
those of you guys you guys who don't eat
meat you guys are stupid so there's
there's a lot of like what a
mean-spirited
dialogue but I don't think it's useful
in any way yeah there's been de
evolution in the civility of discourse
in general that's that's being fomented
by what's happening politically and and
and economically right now yes but you
see it in the health space online you
know in this kind of ongoing you know I
want to call it a discussion but it's
really that would be putting it nicely
people feel like they need to be on some
mud slinging yeah everyone's siloed it
was vegan venom anti anyone who's
there's a tribalism that's happening and
it's really not serving anybody no it's
not it's not so how do we transcend that
I think I think I think it's important
to interact with people that you
disagree with and and to not dislike
them just because you disagree with them
so I think the more and also I think
what happens is what happens is if you
step outside your silo and and adopt a
talking point that doesn't adhere to
your
you know yeah
we just saw this last week when Mark
Duplass a writer director actor in
Hollywood
who's you know like a strident liberal
yeah said hey you know like I had this
encounter with ben shapiro who's a you
know more of a right when he's a
right-wing yeah personality and pundit
and you know if you're gonna if you
really have an interest in expanding
your mind and hearing other people's
opinions like maybe have a look at this
guy and he got crucified and he had to
delete the tweet and i think it came
from a good place in him of trying to
build a bridge but you can't say that if
you're a member of this tribe right
right so he had to take it down and he
had it was a tree was trending on
twitter and he just got reamed you know
and so when i see that like shitty you
said that should he said we can debate
that but the bigger point is how can we
have a civil how can we extend our hand
across the aisle and have a civil
discourse that will move us forward
culturally i think yeah i think too many
people have this all or nothing attitude
it's it's a very binary approach right
so either this or that and I've gotten
flag from vegans for not being more like
oh you should you have a platform you
should be more out there just converting
people and so forth I go look this is
not my thing I'm not gonna be that guy
who disparate someone for lunch or
whatever they're eating plus I don't
think it's effective because they're not
gonna want to have lunch with me again
number one we're not forever we're not
gonna have were not gonna become friends
and they're also gonna have a negative
impression of that you know those vegan
guys are a-holes I had learned from Mike
one time the whole time he's just
telling me about what I'm eating and
I've had many people like I said before
that have other transition to vegan or
are much more in that direction as a
result of becoming friends with me
because they see why do it and so forth
that never would have happened if I just
berated them from the get-go so I think
I think those kind of approaches or I
think also the fact that I feel online
for marketing purposes people often feel
like they have to take a very stringent
approach on something be very
controversial as a way to separate them
self from their heard so if you're a
balanced a reasonable person people like
oh that's boring just kids not it's not
gonna
you know promote its if it's not
clickbait then right you're not [ __ ]
it's called clickbait for a reason yeah
I'm being baited to click right like if
you're taking a balanced approach like
right well let's see what this guy's
nuance is all about yeah yeah exactly
now so a lot of vegans will say you
can't be healthy not only is eating meat
unhealthy for animals which is clearly
true but you can't be healthy at all
doing that now that's not true because
we know a lot people that are healthy
who eat meat right now we can still we
don't like the fact that the meat
because it's hurting animals but let's
not the reasons for not eating meat are
good enough that we don't have to add on
top of that mm-hmm that's kind of where
I go with that and then who opens it
makes you more open to these people
wanting to talk to you you know I've had
people like rod what Rob Wolf's Paleo
diet guy on the podcast he was a really
cool guy no he has different views on
nutrition than I do the whole paleo
family I've had civil you know emails
with Robin yeah and you know does and we
may disagree on certain things but yeah
I noticed like when I was doing research
for this like he wrote a really nice
post about your about all the work that
you've been doing and yeah that's very
nice and all that kind of very nice and
then and then there's there's a lot of
things he's doing that I do like he's
trying to get people to eat more fruits
and vegetables he's saying that and the
animals that the factory farming is
definitely not good for you she care
from these sources now animals are still
being killed you know right so I don't
like those options either but it's
definitely better than factory farming
and that's the other thing it's like oh
it doesn't matter if these animals are
grass fed and all that they're still
dying it's like yes that's true I
understand that completely but you have
to understand that factory farming is so
bad and it there's so much suffering
involved with that that anything that's
in a better direction than that is a
step in the right direction you know the
biggest culprits right of you know
things that we need to go away and I the
great not the great thing I mean the
thing about factory farming is that
that's something we can all unite and
agree on exactly that's where ever you
are nobody is in favor of what's
happened 100 percent a litany of reasons
exactly we can unite on this one issue
alone we can create you know incredible
change exactly and that's where as
someone like Joe Rogan who is he says he
said
negative talk about vegans but not
always he's had people like mac danzig
on there he's been complimentary of me
before on his show but he definitely
agrees that factory forming his factory
farming is harmful and he had the guys
from Cal spirity on there and he
definitely said this is horrible and it
shouldn't be happening right so even
though he's a hunter he's a meteor and
all that that's a common ground we can
all work on and that is the biggest
source of animal suffering yeah agree I
mean I've been on Joe's show twice he's
about to have John Joseph on oh really
cool we've had a little dialog like Joe
really wants to he he sees the toxicity
of this debate right oh yeah and he
really wants to inject it with a little
civility and I really respect the fact
that despite some differences that he
has with people like you and I he's
willing to have us on the show yeah and
he's gonna have John on it and they're
gonna have a discussion about this
really interesting you know he doesn't
have to do that no he doesn't mean and
and I think that that that's really cool
that he could he could lend his giant
platform to a voice that is coming from
a different place from where he's coming
from John Excel is we won't we will
unite on factory farming if anything
right and this is something that really
needs that's got press at the highest
level that's gotta go I mean I think the
future of meat production is not I don't
think the demand for meat is gonna go
away at least not significantly but I
think the way it's manufactured is and
what I mean by that is I think in vitro
meat production that technology is
already being utilized now and I think
that's going to become more ubiquitous
more pervasive there's no question about
it and and ultimately it will render
factory farming exactly and I'm all for
that yeah so I mean if you can I don't
know about what do you mean under those
circumstances and you know you're not
harming an animal so that's that's an
interesting one but I would definitely
be for other people consuming that 100%
and I think people will people would do
it right now if we were available and
cheaper see that's the most important
thing if you're more expensive yeah
convenience and price point it has to be
the healthy choice or the more
environmentally sound or the more
compassionate choice has
to be as accessible as convenient as any
other choice and it has to be at the
same or competitive price point as right
other products and until you get there
you're pushing a rock up a mountain
exactly so it's a hundred I think we're
working towards that and it's exciting
so we're gonna see what happens but I
think so too you know I'm in the same
boat like I'm not that target audience
for lab-grown meat not the target
audience for the impossible burger right
but I'm glad that these things exist
what exactly is the impossible burger is
that something that's injected with in
vitro cells what is that no there's no
there's no animal cells in the
impossible burger it's a plant-based
burger but what they have done that
distinguishes it from the other products
out there like beyond meat is how they
have infused it with some form of heme
iron that gives it that bloody taste
okay it gives it gives it a much more
meat oriented texture and flavor than a
typical plant-based okay got it and that
makes it kind of a game-changer in that
space and there's a lot of people that
love it like it's not for me it's like
it's freaks me out yeah it's just been
so long like I don't need that or what
is that what fat burger is using now and
their petit I know they have a veggie
burger now I'm not sure I know think it
is I paddling out well they have
impossible sliders at White Castle now
okay and they're like every week there's
more and more cheddar that are carrying
it I think you know fast forward a year
to five years it's gonna be pretty much
available everywhere and by that point
the lab-grown meat thing will have come
down in price like this is only gonna
become more and more integrated into
yeah food system yeah a hundred percent
so yeah so I like the direction that we
see the you can't it can't happen soon
enough you know the sooner the better
but at least it's happening yeah all
right so we've we've gone over to ours
and we have a yeah right like we haven't
even we ate we haven't even talked about
kettlebells except for me mentioning how
we haven't talked about it yeah yeah
sure so so this is your thing like you
are early like early
adopt our early fan of kettlebell
training now it's everywhere oh yes
totally bigamous but you trained with
the original guy right pavel thought
Celine
who I know has been on Tim Ferriss his
podcast so convinced me why I need to
start using kettle balls okay as an
endurance athlete well the thing think
about kettlebells is that no wait kettle
balls a lot of people that's always
someone who's ever lose to kettle them
it's like calling kettle biking you go
bike riding or what do they call a
soccer calling it calling football song
right and usually I'm just demonstrating
so I'm a grandparents on this subject
well what I like about kettlebell
training is no weight training system
improves muscular endurance more than
kettlebells that's just lending my
attention now yeah and kettle the
ballistic exercises right kettlebell
swing kettlebell snatch kettlebell clean
and Jurek or push press these are full
body motions where you use your entire
body to project that weight where you
want it to go to you now when you do it
in high repetitions or for time because
there's a kettlebell sport where people
do two lifts for time where it means 10
minutes without putting them down either
it's cleaning two kettlebells and
jerking them overhead and you can rest
here in between reps but you can't put
the bells down for 10 minutes or you're
doing a one-arm snatch which is an
uninterrupted motion of taking the Bell
from the floor to overhead uh-huh and in
10 minutes is you can switch from side
not you can switch once so you can't
switch side to side over and over again
but once but you can't put the belt down
so if you can lift a 70 pound kettlebell
for 10 minutes without putting it down
imagine the structural integrity meaning
your body's ability to delay breaking
down and the endurance that you'll get
from that because you're breathing has
to be on point your structural integrity
has to be on point meaning that your
body's ability to sustain a performance
against time so you don't break down and
then your cardiovascular vo2 max has to
be amazing so developing these things
would definitely help you with what you
do but even taking that aside because I
don't do a lot of V I mean I do high rep
double kettlebell swings and so forth
now so and watch the 10 minute stuff
that's there
never cooked with me but I definitely
see the benefits but even even just set
to 10 which short break set to 20 just
working on volume you're using your full
body so it's not an isolation move so
you're building up a lot of endurance
with it then you're also learning how to
use your body as one unit which
definitely carries over yeah I think
that's that's the big thing the
functional strength aspect of using your
entire body to do a movement with a
heavy weight that is somewhat awkward
and requires not just that isolated that
isolated muscle but rewrite your entire
body yeah that's what distinguishes it
primarily from all of these other sort
of you know weightlifting etc and I do
know a couple things I know the
difference and how I perform and how I
feel as an endurance athlete when I'm
functionally strong and particularly
when my back and my core is strong right
it's a huge difference not because it
necessarily is gonna make me run faster
in the moment but when I start to get
fatigued I'm able to maintain my form I
and my technique for much longer which
then translates into a performance gain
exactly I'm somebody who just wants to
be outside and I'm long so for me it
takes a lot of like mental discipline to
go into the gym and do these things and
and and I call about kettlebells you can
go to a park where I live in Santa
Monica I usually go to the beach and
train with them I'm gonna I've actually
ordered a couple for the house are cool
my coach is really intent on getting me
on this and I've had fits and starts
with it they're my gym has them and my
coach will right out of work out for me
and they all have these crazy names and
I don't know what that means so I go to
the gym and work it out the latest
kettlebell possible because I'm just
skinny and I haven't had I haven't been
in the weight room in a very long time
and and this is I've committed this year
to becoming functionally strong like I
know I need it and that at 51 like you
know my lower back it's tight and I'm a
little creaky in the morning and like
things aren't you know it's like I can't
I just can't get away with stuff I used
to be able to get away with ya know if I
want to continue to perform as an
athlete like this is no longer
negotiable like it's absolutely crucial
no it's that good I delete it for
waistline so I get the latest kettlebell
whatever that is and then I have to go
on YouTube and go I don't even know what
the names of
crazy exercises aren't have to watch a
couple of videos of like the guy doing
it to try to figure it out and I and
then I try to mimic it and I do it in
the most in elegant way I know I'm doing
it wrong I'm like it's something you
need training for yeah I'm supposed to
be this athlete and I'm in here like I
don't know it's like for me I really
have to get out of my comfort zone right
vulnerable because like I'm terrible at
this right but I know that I need to
learn and I'm like committed to doing it
so much so that I that I have ordered
these for the house so that I can do
them here yeah they're fun moves I mean
the kettlebell snatched a double
kettlebell swing is one of my favorites
and that really strengthens up the
hamstrings lower back in particular when
you're using one heavy Bell like you
said your midsection has to engage right
a bit with that and so any any
one-handed lifts especially with high
repetitions your lower back in your
midsection strength is definitely gonna
go way up why did you pick this as your
specific focus especially before it was
a thing yeah I got into it a good friend
of mine at O Sturgis you asked me hey
have you heard of this kettlebell stuff
yet I got now let me take a look
and it looked intriguing to me I never
I'd seen kettlebells in the old time
strongman magazines and so forth but I
didn't really know what you you would do
it was like from the 20s he did these
old strongman guys holding these things
I just thought that maybe they predated
dumbbells and you just did the same
thing that we do with dumbbells with
this I didn't really understand that
there was a whole system of exercises
specific to kettlebell training I was
already a fan of Pavel thought Celine's
work at his power to the people book
it's already liked what he was doing I
liked his message and then I wanted to
get into the fitness industry and I
wanted to get in with the unique selling
points now I wasn't thinking oh let me
go try that that I've never used before
that's gonna be the unique selling point
this was just was in my head when I
started playing around with kettlebells
just for fun I wasn't thinking like let
me learn this as a way to go teach it I
was like let me just play around with
this I enjoyed the movements the
kettlebell snatch in particular came
really fast to me that's that movement
where you take it from the floor to
overhead uh-huh and I got really good at
that fairly fast so yeah so I enjoyed
the aggressive nature of the moves
you're putting up you felt like you were
just tearing something apart it's this
real primal feel to it
so that intrigued me to go take Pavel
sawed Celine
kettlebell certification and this is
2002 in Minneapolis and after taking his
course was how many people showed up for
that probably about 20 people this is
really ER this is the second one he ever
taught the second he taught one before
that that's my friend Steve Maxwell was
that he's been on show so many times too
and I took that course and then things
weren't the same I was like wow this is
also I didn't even have actual
kettlebells then I had this handle but
you put dumbbells on it was a plate
loading kettlebell but I didn't want to
make the investment yes I was just using
that after I took the course though I
immediately bought a SEP so I was like
wow this is totally different and I love
the way these things feel I just like
the whole thing they look cool the
movements are fun and I also felt that
this is a perfect home-based training
system that the average person can
really get behind because the average
person is not really looking to get big
and so forth they want to have more like
you said functional strength they want
to build a play with their kids and not
get tired they want to feel strong and
healthy so I felt that what kettlebells
delivered in the way that Pavel taught
it would be perfect for that audience
right I went on to develop my own style
within it but initially I learned from
him and then I took it in my own way and
my technique is different than what he
teaches and so forth and I learned from
other kettlebell people so it evolved
over time but that was definitely the
most important step for the direction I
ended up taking getting into this whole
have health and fitness thing uh-huh
it started with if it wasn't for the
four years I spent working I didn't work
for Dragon Dora Paul's publisher but I
worked with them heavily meaning that I
taught at a lot of their certifications
there were about five of us that were
considered their elite team they called
them the senior KC's back then and Steve
Maxwell was one of them Steve Carter who
is the best kettlebell instructor by far
he's still out there I don't teach
kettlebells anymore I just do my
supplements now but Steve Carter is the
best kettlebell instructor he's still
out there
and Nate Morrison was there at jf Marton
who's very immersed with CrossFit he's
there he's the kettlebell expert in the
CrossFit world so there were about five
of us that were early adaptors who all
left this organization at one point I
left before some of the other guys did
this guy Jeff left before I did and we
all went on our own directions but the
reason why we were able to go in our own
directions is because we built up
right we had we spent so much time
getting exposed through bubbles
organization he was very generous with
allocating time to all of us it just got
to a point where was I wanted to go my
own way you know I just wasn't happy
being subjugated to their business
philosophy of you know as long as I'm
involved here these are the expectations
that are on me and I go you know what I
want to be my own guy I don't want to be
known as his guy I don't want to be like
oh yeah Mike's one apostles guys I want
to be known as Mike Mahler the Strand
coach in and of himself not because I'm
associated with someone else necessarily
so after four years and it was an
amicable play it wasn't like hey screw
you and all that some of the other guys
had really negative falling outs but
that's the nature of any organization
you know people just butt heads it's
almost impossible so as a endurance
athlete what do you think like if you
were might if I hired you as my strength
coach I mean obviously you'd have to
like evaluate where I'm weak right sort
of stuff but just in general like
there's a lot of endurance athletes
runners triathletes cyclists swimmers
that listen to this show watch the show
what are some key like strength
exercises or perspectives that you could
share like what are the things that like
everybody should be doing who wants to
like an excel in the endurance world I
think I think the most important thing
with a straight training regimen for
endurance athletes is to make your body
more resilient you're not trying to
become more muscular you want to make
your body stronger you want to make your
structural integrity more sound so that
you perform better you know what you do
there so we look at what the we're sorry
I mean there's a huge fear of like they
don't want to be like you're trying to
get lean like it's all about like your
power-to-weight right right Mike right
swing runners you can never get like
they're just trying as skinny as
possible I'm like I don't have you ever
seen a Tour de France cyclist shirt off
but like you know twelve-year-old boys
yeah yeah yeah and they're so terrified
of any additional weight I found like if
you want to have a long career and you
want to remain injury free like you need
to be functionally strong or something's
gonna give
eventually so I would say that you know
shoulders lower back ankles and so forth
feet strength is really important that's
why a lot of us do strain training
barefoot I like to do my sprinting
barefoot in front Vibrams you know I'm
not running
bare feet on a field so I mean basically
just making the body more sound like
Frank Shamrock oh he said that he did a
lot of body building stuff not
necessarily to make his body look a
certain way but so that his strength was
sound he didn't have him balances so
that when he's fighting when you're
fighting you're using certain muscle
groups more than the others so it's
actually important to use the muscle
groups that you're not using in your
sport running training or balance right
and that's why bodybuilding gave him
because people are like bodybuilding
that's not functional you don't use
those moves in in the actual sport and I
think that's a mistake too with a lot of
strength training now is you're actually
trying to mimic the moves that somebody
does with resistance and that's not
necessarily the best way to go out there
I'm not gonna hold a kettlebell and
throw punches with it that's not that's
gonna change the technique I'm not gonna
take a heavier basketball and try to
shoot that because that changes the
technique now I'm not gonna put a weight
vest on and go sprinting because my
technique with the vest on is gonna be
different than without so it's actually
gonna be counterproductive so you if the
looking at a strengthen the supportive
muscles exactly everything that gets
atrophied through the repetitive motion
of whatever the specific sport is
exactly
so whatever imbalances you have your
strength training regimen should address
it so that you're not imbalanced any
more and you're less injury prone the
most important thing that a strength and
conditioning program does is make you
less injury prone like Steve Maxell
makes a great point of saying you should
never get injured when you're lifting
weights because the whole point of
lifting weights is to make your body
stronger so that you don't get injured
in your sport so the last thing you want
to do is push it so hard with weight
training that you get injured I mean
imagine him someone who's a UFC fighter
and they they decide to find out what
their deadlift max is now they blow out
their back and that was like well I had
a million dollar payday on Saturday I
guess that's gone right there's the gym
and everyone's watching you know it's a
big dick measuring I don't think a lot
of those guys care I mean someone like
John Jones is really into powerlifting
but he's an anomaly that guy's just good
at whatever he does he's just extremely
gifted if he's dead lifting 600 pounds
and he's he's just started maybe this
was after maybe six months after
starting you know this is unheard of but
he's just a gifted athlete but he's but
someone like him I wouldn't I wouldn't
have anyone who is well first of all
there's really no reason to max out at
all let's start there if you're a power
lifter
you do it for your sport but pretty much
every Power lifter has serious injuries
at some point they do a long enough
that's so not so it's not about going to
failure no I think you should stay away
from failure like I lift weights with
like right now I'm looking really
frequently I'll deadlift five days a
week but I only do three sets of five
with 70% of my one rep max you know so
that's about four hundred and five
pounds from me I'm just working on
technique I'm working on technique and I
want my back to feel great afterwards I
don't want any tightness and as a result
of not lifting so heavy I can do it more
often and if I do it more often I get
better neurologically I get better and
just from the simple act of doing it and
that's probably pavo's most poeple
sullens most important contribution is
this high frequency of training with
keeping several reps in the bank staying
very far from failure it's all the other
problem with going to failure is that I
need a couple days of rest that in your
technique is never good on that last rep
right you go to failure and number 10 is
the only is the last rep you can do it's
not gonna look like number one through
seven even that even a few reps before
that rep your technique probably started
degrading and what about like heavy
weight low rap versus low weight high
rap yeah that just depends on the
context as well so I mean if you're weak
in those areas and improving it would be
useful to you so for example like a UFC
fighter that the stronger you are the
better you are you know to a point so if
your technique is great and you and you
get stronger you're gonna be a better
fighter
so getting and then a lot of these guys
have to our men and women have to stay
within certain weight classes so lifting
heavy weights and low reps that allows
you to get a lot stronger without
getting bigger
that's pretty much the way I train so
I'm not trying to get bigger even the
size I have is more of a side effect of
the training it was new it was not
necessarily intense you know early on it
was as I said I wanted to kind of build
a shield to protect myself but at this
point I'm not trying to get bigger I
just like lifting I just I like King I
like I like the act of demonstrating
strength mm-hmm yeah so for me like
where I'm in a very low resistance high
rep you know sports right basically
going long distances would I be better
served by doing heavy weight low rep I
think so you do yeah
because it's also you're also gonna be
one you're gonna be way less sore from
that and two it's gonna it's it's a
totally different stimulus than what
you're used to just someone doing and
you can not to say that you can't do
some high repetition maybe at the end of
a workout you do a finisher kettlebell
swings or snatches or you just throw it
in the mix but that wouldn't be my the
focus of the regimen it would be more
heavy weights low repetitions to make
your body more resilient and to a point
and again it wouldn't be anywhere close
to failure so these wouldn't be maximum
efforts they would be challenging but
not to the point where an injury is even
likely or even close to being likely
yeah I got it man all right we got to
wrap this up but I want to leave people
with
I want to go back to the hormone thing
yeah sure you know I want to leave
people with some things that they can
take away and and implement it in their
own life like to get a better sense of
whether their hormonal e abnormal and
some practices to help optimize hormone
functionality well I mean one thing
people can do the one test you can do
that doesn't cost anything is like
Charles Poliquin has this whole bio
signature approach right where he goes
where where you hold body fat is an
indicator of your hormone imbalance so
if you have a lot of pictorial fat
that's way too much conversion of
testosterone to estrogen if you have a
lot of stomach fat that's basically
adrenal issues your cortisol so this is
whether you're a male or exactly this is
this is across both sexes so you can do
the merit test and just look at where
you store a body fat that gives you a
pretty accurate idea it's not 100%
accurate but it gives you a pretty good
indicator of what's going on with you if
you have a lot of tricep fat it means
low androgens means your testosterone
estrogen ratio is not is poor and most
are more often than not blood work will
confirm the assessment from this I'm not
saying that it sits in place of it but
that's something you can do right now
get an idea and a lot of this is I mean
we look at ourselves in the mirror
everyday is that nothing's gonna be a
big surprise like oh wow I didn't I
didn't think about that until you
brought it up so you now you just know
why it's happening
maybe you're storing a lot of stomach
fat because you're under a lot of stress
and if you want to get rid of that
stomach fat training and nutrition are
important but you have to mitigate the
stress as well otherwise you're just
gonna hold on to it so that's one thing
people gonna do blood testing I
recommend direct labs calm if you want
to bypass a doctor you can go to direct
labs calm they have different panels
for men and women if you don't know how
to interpret the results it's not going
to be that useful so then you can
contact someone like dr. Thomas England
on or dr. mark Gordon dr. Nick Delgado
all three of those people are really
good right one of the things that you
recommended in one of the articles that
you wrote is that you shouldn't that
your workouts shouldn't shouldn't exceed
one hour yeah that doesn't work for me
[Laughter]
provide some context I get what you're
saying though yeah I can provide some
context though it's an intense workout
shouldn't last more than an hour I got
you some people they go to the gym and
they're just [ __ ] around they're
taking selfies and so forth they don't
need to finish that up and for you I
mean if they should but let said that
workout is it's not they're not training
so intensely that it's gonna be negative
now here's the thing if you workout
really hard you're not gonna want to go
more than forty five man yeah that's
what my workouts are forty-five minutes
I was like dude I thought you were in
the gym like eight hours a day sometimes
it's even less nap cuz I train
frequently right actually in five six
days a week so when I go sprinting it's
ten hundred yard dashes that doesn't
take long I just drive to there close by
feel bang out the runs and come home
that's less than twenty minutes easily
and then with my weight training workout
somebody do at the home gym somebody at
a gym to you but it's always a couple
compound drills three or four movements
four movements at the most sometimes
it'll be squats weighted ring pull-ups
and some kind of overhead press and then
that's it maybe glute/ham raises or some
kind of torso work dragon Flags is one
of my favorite that Bruce Lee exercise
that's one of my favorite to have
exercises but you get so much abdominal
strength from heavy deadlifts and heavy
squats and also ring pull-ups weighted
especially and overhead that your your
midsection is getting is getting hit
even though you don't hit it directly so
I I don't think any of this stuff has to
be consumed a lot of your time these
workouts don't take me more than 15 to
20 minutes I go in my garage I hit three
or four moves I'm out of there one of
the things that you also talk about on
the nutrition side of this I mean like
we could talk about superfoods we talked
about ginger and turmeric about that
forever but really basic stuff like
spices like cinnamon and everybody has
or like you know starting your day with
water with like lime and sea salt yeah
things like that says you like talk us
through me
can kind of wrap it up with just a few
few of these yeah yeah there's a couple
things you can add today for so every
morning I start with I take a lime and I
squeeze it into about 12 ounces of water
and put a little bit of sea salt in
there and what this does is basically it
nourishes your adrenals so it's a great
tonic first thing in the morning and
it's very alkaline as well and it's very
cleansing I mean you're gonna have to go
to the bathroom with it you know a few
minutes of doubting this it just cleans
you right out you're feeling good so I
do that every morning that's a good
morning ritual and that's something
anyone everyone can add that right now
like well I don't know if I have adrenal
issues you probably do know if you live
in society you probably do you just get
this in it has a lot of health benefits
anyway so that's one thing people can do
the spices I like to add ginger nutmeg
and cinnamon to all my protein shakes I
only have one a day but I add it to that
and then with cook meals basil garlic
made not only does it make the food
taste better but you're just amping up
the health properties of it even more so
and it's easy you just add it right in
there mm-hmm yeah that's good and what's
your what's like a day a day in the life
of food like say so it's some days I do
intermittent fasting well I'll wake up
I'll have the lime and sea salt and then
I might have a cup of coffee with almond
milk a little bit of stevia and then I
won't eat until later on in the day a
lot of days when I am when I'm gonna be
lifting heavy weights because I like to
lift weights about four to six hours
after waking up your body is
decompressed you're less likely to get
injured and I just feel stronger I'm not
thinking about lifting heavy weights
first thing in the morning body's tight
you know I need to loosen up through
mobility exercises so I I do it some
joint mobility exercises that I learned
from Steve Maxwell and Paul basalt
saline and I have a YouTube clip it's me
and my dogs doing it in the backyard it
takes more doesn't take more in ten
minutes and that's something I like to
do every day if I slack on that I feel
it right I get tight real fast
especially if you're lifting heavy
weights and just getting older so that's
part of the routine and then I'll have
this super shake where it's eight ounces
of almond milk eight ounces of water 3
tablespoons of hemp seeds one tablespoon
of flax seeds one scoop of organic food
bar protein powders is one of the ones I
like has five different vegan proteins
in it a teaspoon of ginger maybe 1/4 of
a teaspoon of nutmeg cinnamon
what else do I add in there I take a
tablespoon of cacao and then I
a bunch of frozen fruit so acai mango
blueberries whatever whatever fruits
people like they can add in their dry
have to be those I blend that up and
this is a big shake and then like I was
saying earlier I just drink one glass at
a time that gets me through the entire
day I don't have a big meal until much
later in the evening right and that'll
be a stir-fry usually I'm just a lot of
vegetables and some kind of some some
legumes so maybe Monday it'll be black
beans Tuesday garbanzo beans out of
zucchini it's a different legume each
day sync it up yeah exactly what is when
people come up to you and say well what
about protein or and what you know what
how do you answer that well you know but
since we're essentially thing about
protein is that I used to get
chiropractic adjustments from Franco
Columbu when I lived out here in Los
Angeles and he still has a chiropractic
office
zeruel yeah he does he's just so
surprised I know that you should usually
go to him just for the hell of it but
anyway I talked to him a lot about
training and nutrition and he told me
that even when he and Arnold were in
their heyday the only ate one gram of
protein per kilo which is considered
extremely low by today's standards and
then they would add in your daily
recommendation is 0.74 just an average
human yeah and I think is our name I
think I don't think you need that much I
don't know so one gram a kilo per one
gram a kilo and then 30 to 40 grams when
you're trying to put on size so if
they're just maintaining they don't even
do that just an extra 30 to 40 grams of
protein now these guys are big meat
eaters they're not doing it because you
know a vegan diet is inherently lower in
protein so maybe you're trying to skew
the fact to say you don't need protein
that's not what they're doing but what
they what and then people will say well
they were taking steroids I was like
well steroids improve protein
utilization so that would be more reason
to take even more protein right so the
fact that they're on our bollocks and
that's all they felt what they need it
for protein says a lot and these guys
also did a pretty high carbohydrate diet
about 60% of calories coming from
carbohydrates and in fat was I think 15
to 20 percent right so it's quite a bit
different in these guys look great that
was the Golden Age of bodybuilding
people like Franco Columbu and
Schwarzenegger and Frank Zane
these guys looked incredibly team 7088
or whatever yes exactly so one I don't
think you need one gram per pound to
definitely don't need that and some
recommend even more than that and I just
think that's absurd are they won grand
prix
which is what I get so I weight 200
pounds I get around 90 to 100 grams of
protein sometimes less sometimes more
right you know just depends and I've
gone through periods where I've taken a
lot more protein and never found it to
have any additional benefit I wasn't
getting strong or fast or a game bigger
my friend Christian Thibodeau who's a
strength very well respected strength
coach he said the same thing and he's a
big guy he's jacked here and he weighs
around maybe 230 pounds solid and he
said that he never found any more than
150 grams of protein and even that was
that beneficial right and most of these
big guys are eating multiples of that
yeah yeah exactly and then but they're
also taking anyone that's a professional
bodybuilder they're using anabolics as
well now you can get away with a lot and
when you're doing a bollocks and you
could say that that's more the reason
why they're at a certain size look I'm
amber testosterone a magazine wrote this
article about you know how to how to
survive with the high-protein lifestyle
what they meant is tell me the name of
that magazine this is called tea nation
calm are you serious as of magazine
called testosterone nation it's just
called tea - nation it's just a websites
not it's not a physical magazine they
had a physical magazine for a little bit
these are guys who used to be with
muscle media 2000 and then they ventured
off I mean they've been doing this for a
long time 1990s but anyway they talked
about how a lot of body builders have
serious flatulence because they eat so
much protein and how some of the big
bodybuilders at Gold's Gym would carry
around lysyl containers with them these
are just farting on command everywhere
they go okay now if that's something
you're doing you're taking in way too
much of something so let's let's get to
the point of and also here's the other
thing longer stretches in between meals
better digestion better digestion means
less need for protein intake because if
you're digesting more of the protein
less food intake and junk yeah exactly I
don't even eat as much as a lot of
people think Oh any most people think I
probably eat five six thousand calories
I probably eaten less than 2500 calories
a day but what I'm eating is very high
in nutrition forget about calories it's
very nutritious in the more nutrition
you take in the less you have to worry
about calories right that's my take so I
think a lot of things we have been
taught we just believe because someone
said it but there really isn't anything
to substantiate
so
you do do some plant-based protein in
your smoothie what else do you
supplement with and I know you have your
own line of something yeah I mean I I
take one of my favorite supplements is
one eye cells called restores I'm it's a
systemic enzyme which lowers
inflammation by it induces healing so it
lowers didn't the need for inflammation
and if I could recommend one thing that
you will be that because that will help
tremendously with aches and pains yeah I
think I see you were nice enough to send
me a box of your stuff yeah you need
more just let me know that's my favorite
if I could only take one supplement it
would be systemic enzymes and people are
surprised when they hear that because
they go man your testosterone booster is
so awesome it's a natural testosterone
booster your brain communicates with
your testes more to signal more
testosterone production and it works
extremely well way better than anything
on the market doesn't come close just
just look at the testimonials from
people that have used it nothing comes
close that's my second favorite product
because as you get older your I mean
it's not even so much as you're getting
older it's just is this more wear and
tear right it's more mileage those of us
that are working hard physically and on
our businesses and in our life and we're
being we're being inundated with
different stresses what about b12 D I
take a beat I take a B 100 which has b12
but at that way I get all the B vitamins
covered I don't take an actual b12
vitamin d3 I do take and I actually did
score a low on that and they did a blood
test a while back which is not too
surprising because it's so hot in Las
Vegas
we're not out in the Sun all day long
you know so I mean if I am out in the
Sun I'm not walking around half-naked or
anything the irony of being like the
sunniest place I know is that you might
outweigh it it's like I have to take
vitamin D in a sunnier but ridiculous
yeah but I do take that and there's
vegan options for d3 right and I'm
playing around with DHEA cream right now
because that is really intriguing to me
and DHEA cream not only increases DHEA
levels if you get the right one right
there's a company that is a former
compound pharmacy guy so he created a
DHEA cream which delivers through the
skin really well a lot of the ones in
the market they don't deliver well at
all so you don't you don't end up
increasing DHEA or anything useful I'm
just playing around with that because
sometimes for me when I go through
periods of stress my DHEA can be
depleted I'm just playing around with
that to see how I feel how different I
feel what I'm using that so I tend to
play around with a couple what's quite
few things but the staples are that
restores on my testosterone booster I
used eight weeks on four off because you
never want to get too adapted to any
herbs I'm a strong believer in cycling
herbs I have an adrenal energy product
called red which has rhodiola and has
ashwagandha chillage it's an maca now
that's really good for rejuvenating your
adrenals and those of us that are
working out hard just giving you more
adaptogen properties that magnesium oil
I love putting on before going to sleep
because I do sleep a lot but I'm a light
sleeper is anything that helps me relax
because I'm always thinking you know
when you're I think I'm just naturally a
thinker but when you're an entrepreneur
you tend to always be thinking of stuff
have you experimented with CBD oil I
have yeah I like CBD oil I you know I
use marijuana recreationally just for
fun you know not something like everyday
to go to sleep or anything like that but
if we're that's that's my recreational
mr. alcohol you know that would be
something I use if I want to go to a
concert or something like that not
driving around on it just so people know
I'm down there spending the night but uh
CPD I think is great for pain
inflammation some of my dogs take it I
have an older dog he's a senior he's got
some heart issues so I give it to him
just to keep him calm it was hearts
enlarged so I have to keep his lifestyle
as stress-free as possible so that he's
good to go on that so I do like CBD yeah
I've never noticed anything profound
taking it right like I've never taken it
and been like oh wow I know this so I
got bone-on-bone arthritis in this elbow
and I've had stem cells injected in
there which helped the most yeah there's
a friend of mine in Vegas dr. Garcia I
had these mesenchymal stem cells
injected in there that helped a lot but
I've got this bone spur in there where
it looked like it exploded so it's
everywhere and I can't have them
operated on or shaved down because I
went to a couple surgeon they say it's
too close to the nerve so that impinge
is full range of motion like I can't
extend this arm fully but what the stem
cells did is they got rid of the pains I
used to be in pain all the time and I
just dealt with it I was like oh well
I'm gonna have to deal with this and it
was a nuisance stuff because you're
always aware of it right but once I got
the stem cells in there the pain went
away pretty fast so that's been pretty
powerful yes CBD oil is I mean for me
like I haven't I've tried it a couple
times I think it helps me sleep a little
bit but it also gives me it kind of
makes me depressed really yeah
I've gotten that with certain things
like I remember I tried say me one time
which everyone said was great for a mood
I actually found it to be the opposite
and actually made me really depressed
yeah so you different man yeah we're
also going which is kind of goes back to
the whole thing with your hormonal yeah
like you know so so somebody's listening
to this and they're like man I should
think more about this I should look into
where I'm at with this whole hormone
thing like should they get a blood test
like what's the first thing somebody
should do to get on top of it and begin
the process of trying to optimize this
well what I would do is one go check out
run article I wrote on leptin just to
remind yourself of all things we discuss
it that's on my website mic male comm I
have a hormone optimization lecture
series T which it's eight hours it's
fifty dollars it's really comprehensive
so that's good stuff information to have
to refer back to you in terms of testing
like I said you can go get the blood
work done but if you don't know how to
interpret the results it's not gonna be
that useful and sure you can resource
these things but it's always good to
have a set of professional eyes anything
you're doing is there a place where
either you can go and figure out if
there's a doctor or a professional in
your area
who knows what they're talking about
with this stuff not that I'm aware of
and honestly it's it's hard for me to
recommend someone I don't know
personally you know and stuff like this
I'm sure there's plenty of good doctors
out there that I don't know that are
great but I've also had a lot of people
like giving me negative experiences
they've had with anti-aging doctors
where they walk in there and they just
want to get them on stuff it's like all
your testosterone is low let's get you
on this to a growth hormones let's get
you on that it's like well let's get my
advice is to work with someone that
wants to address underlying functional
medicine integrative medicine
I think Delgado is great Nick Delgado
and he does distance consulting I think
dr. Thomas in Cologne he's based in
Phoenix Arizona
but he also does distance and what I
like about him is the first phone call
with him is free where he'll assess your
situation and he'll let you know if he
can help before he charges you anything
and he'll have you do even more
comprehensive testing such as mineral
imbalances and so forth because you
could have low testosterone because your
copper and zinc are low you know and you
just addressed as zinc imbalance all of
a sudden your testosterone is great
complicated it is yeah it really is
that's why it's it's hard to stay you
know just do this one thing and you're
going to be great because you need to
know the more you know
about your exact situation the better it
is to know what to do about it and
otherwise it's just a guessing game so
you get the testosterone test done and
it's low okay
we don't know why it's Lola this could
be so many reasons why slow it could be
lifestyle could be stress maybe you hate
your job and it may take you quite a
while to figure that out yeah exactly
that's why it's good to have someone who
knows what they're doing what he or she
is doing look at it because they've seen
this kind of stuff a million times no
Thomas inkling on it's not gonna look at
your lab work or mine and be surprised
by anything he's gonna be like yeah I've
seen this before I know what they do
that's what you want you want someone
looking at it going you know what I know
exactly what to do instill that
confidence alright man thank you talking
to you man that was awesome thank you
very much pleasure for informational and
you gave me a lot to think about and I'm
excited for my kettlebell training
kettlebell I said Carol you got it man
thank you so much thank you I really
appreciate it that was really cool if
you're digging on Mike you can find him
at Mike Muller calm as it h yeah you're
at Mike Mahler on Twitter you gotta like
unlock your Instagram right after this
Mike baller 73 on Instagram and Facebook
is a aggressive strength right yeah so
and if you just go to my website all the
all the bunnies there exactly on there
and the live life aggressively podcast
and the book by the same name yeah yeah
my friend sincere Hogan and I do the
show we've been doing it for five years
and it's a lot of fun so I encourage
people to check that out and check it
out man thank you so much all right dude
be good thank you
[Music]